what's up y'all as always welcome
whenever and wherever you might be
watching I'm excited for tonight I'm
very excited for tonight the theme is
Big lies plural big lies this will
become more apparent the longer the
night goes on if you're a former
Adventist or if you've ever engaged with
an Adventist at any length of time
you're going to know that one of the SDA
Church's favorite slogans is that they
are the Commandment keeping church one
of which is the ninth
commandment in case you have
forgotten you shall not give false
testimony against your
neighbor I've said on this platform and
I will continue continue to that when
the SDA Church claims to be the
Commandment keeping church that is
really a euphemism we have talked about
this before if you've been here for any
length of time you know what that
euphemism is it is a euphemism for we go
to church on Saturday because another
thing I've constantly said and will
continue to say is that the Commandment
keeping Church's favorite commandment to
break is the ninth commandment it is
hard-coded into their system of theology
where they constantly bear false witness
about the Christian church as well as
those of us who have left their ranks so
tonight we're going to be taking a look
at a whole host of Big lies that the SDA
church and her apologists have engaged
in and the acts of damage control that
they use to try and cover them up with
me to discuss
this who has also been a Target by the
way of some of these big lies Dr Steve
Daly for those that do not know Dr Dy is
the author of 28 books 10 of of them are
directly related to LG white and
adventism he taught religion history and
psychology at the University level with
a 24-year tenure in 7th Day Adventist
institutions including lomalinda
University and laserra University during
those years he was also a campus
chaplain and Pastor he has been licensed
as a psychologist since 1992 with his
PhD in Psychology he also holds an MA in
history and a doctorate in religion from
Claremont School of Theology where his
dissertation integrat history and
religion related to Ellen White and
adventism we are also going to be
discussing some of the
contents of his newest book The White
estate fraud sth day adventism
scandalous untold story in the synopsis
of the book The Publisher writes this
for years dissenting voices have been
silenced their character tarnished and
critical information distorted Dy sets
the record straight debunking the claims
that DM canite the author whose book
exposed the fraud Within in the church
has uh had recanted drawing on
meticulous research daily exposes the
shocking inner workings of the
SDA so we're going to get into quite a
bit tonight first we're going to start
by interacting with some of the claims
that SDA academics have made about Steve
as well as some of their defenses to
some of the claims in his books and let
you the viewer see where the evidence
stands after that we will then
transition into the specifics of his
book which you can purch on Amazon a
link to that is in the description box
down below no it's not an affiliate link
I get nothing for it um I just support
the book and think that you should too
because it is a treasure Trove of
information but before bringing him in I
want to remind you that you can visit
answering adventism domcom for more
resources to partner with us sign up for
our monthly newsletter and so much more
this resource is our gift to you it is
packed with information please use it
simply type in a name in this powerful
search bar a phrase a subject and click
enter and it'll take you to everything
on the website within that category
topic or that uses that word you can use
it for phrases contradictions uh names
Doug Bachelor etcc and you can browse to
your heart's desire we receive a lot of
questions via email and it is hard to
get back to all of them which is in part
why this website exists so please check
out the website first you may be able to
get an answer quicker that way with that
said I want to get right into it here
Steve thank you for being here sir hey
thanks so much miles for the invitation
appreciate it absolutely so like I
mentioned first I want to look at some
statements from a couple of admin of
Scholars about you DM canite and those
of us I would be under the umbrella as
well that have been critical of their
movement then I want to get into the big
lies plural that you talk about in your
book so first in Dr Jud Lake's book I'm
a former student of Dr Lake Ellen White
Under Fire he starts off by spending the
first two chapters poisoning the well
basically um by claiming all critics of
Ellen White our modern day DM canright
parrots and as I'm sure you're aware um
mentioning that name in Advent circles
is kind of like you know just letting
the bomb go off of Just toxin um you
know apostate heretic Arch you know
archal heretic um and he refers to him
as the father of Ellen White criticism
this is a recurring theme from the SDA
Church uh for those that do not know and
her apologists still use this as you're
going to see multiple times this evening
but he goes into can right's history to
essentially say that he had a personal
ax to grind with the church and the
fruit of that has been now a bunch of
people in in the modern day parting his
personal Grievances and angst against
adventism um he at least had uh enough
honesty to admit that the review and
Herald actually started all of that
maybe we'll get into some of that later
but notice what he
writes he says quote Dudley M K right's
departure from 7th Day adventism and his
subsequent lengthy campaign to discredit
its prophetic messenger can be
considered a critical turning point in
the history of Ellen White criticism for
four reasons these are the four reasons
first in the culmination of his work the
life of Mrs EG white he recycled the
criticisms of Ellen White's prophetic
Ministry from 1845 to the late 1880s
covered in the previous chapter second
he conceived new criticisms against her
such as the plagiarism and epilepsy
charges he also or he was also the first
one to systematically associate Ellen
with cult leaders in the 18th and 19th
centuries such as Emanuel swedenborg uh
Ann Lee Staley from the Shakers Joseph
Smith of the Mormons Mary Baker Ed Mary
Baker Eddie of the Christian scientists
and Charles T Russell of the Jehovah's
Witnesses third canri raised almost all
the issues that would be directed
against Ellen White in the future most
of the criticisms circulating the
internet today are recycled from can
right's complaints even when an
occasional new criticism is posted it
still stands in the framework of his
strategy fourth canri provided a model
that almost all future critics of Ellen
White would copy from the non-adventist
Evangelical critics of the early 20th
century to the former Adventist critics
of today that's us most of them have
followed the pattern he laid out in life
of Mrs EG white and have considered this
volume to be influential in their
thinking in this sense therefore
canright can be called the father of
Ellen White criticisms close
quote so we will get into who DM
canright is in a little bit but Steve my
question for you is that true are your
books 28 of them 10 of which have to do
with you know in the same vein are your
books criticizing Ellen White simply
recycled claims that canri made no
absolutely not uh I uh I would agree
with uh Lake that um you know can was
certainly one of the most influential
early critics but he certainly wasn't
the first miles Grant uh was before can
write and he you know that's one reason
I wrote my
psychobiography was
to study uh the research question will
the accusations of Fraud and pathology
leveled against Ellen White throughout
her lifetime and after her lifetime
stand up to
historical and psychological scrutiny
and uh so I went through all the critics
um I looked at all of them and canri was
certainly a very influential one but I
relied very little on him in my book I
think I quoted him once um so the the
notion that I simply pared canr which is
you know there's a strategy here in
adventism they feel like they have
discredited canr which of course we know
isn't true now especially since the
white estate fraud has come out it shows
that they're the ones who discredited
themselves not canr and that canr was
actually a very uh great man of
integrity and a humble man a man who
didn't have a axe to grind against
adventism and actually wanted to have a
very peaceful truce and it was the
Adventists who insisted on breaking that
and the review and Herald repeatedly
before canri decided to defend himself
but um you know I I I can't say that I'm
very impressed with Lake uh I wish he
would have come on and debated me
because uh I find his arguments to be
very weak and unscholarly and um you
know I think he just falls into the same
category that uh the
apologists uh who even call themselves
Scholars fall into which is they
don't seriously address the source
documentation in my psychobiography not
a single one of them has done that you
know I had top egw Scholars on my uh
reading committee for the uh
psychobiography I had 21 people on there
including Ron numbers Jonathan Butler
Ron
grael Gil Valentine they were all on
there and not a single one of them
questioned or challenged my source
documentation in the book so that it's
not surprising that Tim and Jud Jud Lake
and these other people aren't doing it
and certainly not any of the other
critics that come on my thread on a
daily basis um they never address the
source documentation of Ellen White's
own words her own actions her lifetime
patterns
that's what uh my conclusions are based
on and I looked at all the critics in
the process of doing that and can write
is certainly a noteworthy one but the
reason Adventists love to uh hold up
canr and say we're all copycats of canr
is because they have this false uh
narrative that they've discredited can
right and that's absolutely untrue and
that's why I wrote this last book to
show it's it's absolutely untrue and
they're guilty of uh not only you know
gross dishonesty but when you absolutely
fabricate a book and claim to be a man's
secretary and try to destroy him with
his own Diaries after he's dead when you
never even met the man and Arthur white
colluded with this for 20 years secretly
denying it on top of that I mean you're
talking about some extreme pathology
here that uh
is really ugly and and you know and
Advent Adventists are trying to defend
that let's just put it that
way yeah and so the thing that we're
going to get into a bunch of that by the
way folks um in in a lot more detail the
thing that really bothers me about Dr
Lake's book uh I like Dr Lake like I
said I'm I'm a former student of his
nice guy um but man his criticisms are
just sorry man they're just they don't
cut it they don't actually like all like
you mentioned um there's zero engagement
with the actual claims the only
engagement I've ever found around the
real issues is omitting certain details
like oh we're not going to talk about
the fact that uh in that first Vision
she's literally just plagiarizing Joseph
Turner's paper she claims she she was
getting a headache when she was would
read so she didn't see it even though
she was left alone with the paper and
just happened to you know the thing he
talked about at the meeting that she
wasn't able to go to because she didn't
feel good it just happened to be what
she saw in Vision um she was alone with
the paper but didn't look at the paper
she knew nothing about it um they're not
addressing that Turner said that that
was exactly what he said right and and
even Roger Olsen in his you know his I
was I was somewhat impressed at least by
the fact that he he did a big write up I
don't know if you've seen it on the
white States website um it was probably
posted somewhere else back in the day
and then just transcribed to to digital
but I was at least somewhat impressed
with the fact that he tried to deal with
the shutd door problem he didn't touch
that we went over it uh months ago um on
the channel we went over this whole
issue and we looked at his uh write up
and he completely Dodges all of the
actual issues he only deals he deals he
loves the the later quotes you know I
never claimed I never said you know one
word in in what 71 um or or whatever it
was I never claimed yeah an 84 or
whatever it was um I never I never
claimed this well you either have a
terrible memory um or you're just line
because you did and it's documented the
thing that bothers me though about lak's
book is that he he really just engages
in the genetic fallacy instead of actual
criticism it's irrelevant if krite was
the first or 200th person to point these
things out that has no bearing on
whether or not it's true and he never
really addresses the criticisms
throughout the book he simply claims
canite misunderstood Ellen's role had a
faulty what he calls a rigid view of
inspiration that's the term he uses over
and over these they have these this real
rigid view of inspiration AKA uh God
should be able to communicate uh
effectively but he really actually deals
uh he never actually deals with the
substance of of of the claims um canr
had zero bearing on me leaving the SDA
church I've talked about this a lot I
wasn't even aware of him until many
years after leaving adventism if
anything the Protestant reformers had
far more influence on me leaving
adventism than any sort of former
Adventist um I didn't really even I
didn't even really grow up hearing about
canr other than the sort of vague
references to you know the apostates and
the critics Etc but it's also an
interesting insight for people to see
how Adventists are quick to associate
all the other sects that rose up in the
same time period as Colts but not
seventh day adventism they get a pass
for some reason because he says he says
you know K right's the originator of of
pointing out you know that Ellen White's
no different than Ann Lee of the Shakers
and and all these other figures and
there's sort of this undertone which I'm
sure you saw that being an SDA academic
there's the they're quick to say oh yeah
all these other groups they're Cults but
we're not right so you get the
undertones of that in his book precise
in a few weeks I'll be doing a fuller
response to Dr L's book as well as a
talk that he gave regarding this um but
that's point one the SDA church folks
loves making the claim that anyone who
is critical of them and their errant
theology is just a parrot of canr which
is the SDA Church essentially
postulating that they've dealt with all
those criticisms before there's nothing
new Under the Sun don't even listen to
what saying that's the sort of messaging
that's precise
Steve because Steve now I want to get
your thoughts on some claims made by the
associate director of the Adventist
biblical Research Institute Alberto Tim
who is also the former associate
director of the white estate he had
quite a bit to say about you by name and
your previous book Ellen White a
psychobiography in an article from May
20121 that was titled Steve Daly on
Ellen White and I've heard you talk of a
lot on a number of you know the the the
Christian Scholars Forum on Peter
Dixon's SDA Q&A we're going to play a
clip from that later actually um and
after reading this article um I remember
thinking to myself uh that doesn't sound
like what Steve is actually saying um
this sounds like the standard M Mo so
I'll be curious to hear your thoughts on
some of these I want to look at a
several a number of of claims that he
makes about you the first is with
regards to your positive statements
about white apparently from many moons
ago and then your subsequent uh
criticisms that have come later on so
notice what he
writes he says
quote how can we explain the contrast
between dy's previous Pro Ellen White
position and his present anti- Ellen
White
stand daily points to the publication on
the internet of new material I have
found from suppressed areas of the white
estate vault which I wasn't even allowed
to see as a historian he says he even
suggests the evidence used to support
the validity of these criticisms was
very convincing then when white was
still alive and is even more
overwhelmingly today given the new
research that has come to light but this
qu but this question requires a more
convincing answer than just access to
new historical information White's
unpublished writings to which he refers
have been available for study by
historians and researchers at egy Estate
research centers including the white
estate branch office at Lolinda
University long before they were made
available publicly on the
internet further the major criticisms
against white DM canite Ronald numbers
Walter Ray and a few others were already
available when Dy published his
adventism for a new generation in
1993 several of which he had cited in
his ma theist how readest thou could it
be that what really happened was a rap
radical change in his own perspective in
which all the critics of white became
reliable sources of information and all
Adventist responses to those critics
were discarded as unreliable
excuses close quote so Steve he claims
that you seemed to praise Ellen White at
one point but then began siding with all
of the known critics as reliable sources
of information while discarding and
ignoring Adventist responses to those
critics is this hypothesis
correct absolutely not uh Tim uh really
disappoints me I I don't know if he's
deliberately dishonest or if he's just
uh not very sophisticated in terms of
understanding research but um you know
the bottom line is that when you do
research you have a research question
and you explore that question that's
what I did when I wrote myam thesis on
the 1919 Bible Conference that's what I
did when I wrote the irony of adventism
on Ellen White at Claremont I was
looking at the Paradox between Ellen
White being a female leader and how
avenus women were treated in general in
the church and even by her and um you
know my PhD and psychology again was on
adventism Adventist adolescence and
addiction a very specific
question when you do research you don't
Cover the Waterfront you know if a
person's claiming to write a biography
on a on a figure then you're expected to
look at all sides which of course adenus
have totally failed to do with regard to
Ellen White every single biographer has
completely failed to look at the Dark
Side of Ellen White to look at the
immorality to look at the lifelong
patterns of dis honesty there's a huge
amount of stuff there that a biographer
is obligated to look at if they're going
to write a biography of a person I was
not writing a biography of Ellen White I
made that very clear in the
psychobiography psychobiography can
focus specifically on pathology uh
there's a wide spectrum of things that
psychobiologist can focus on I gave my
research question
very specifically that I already
mentioned will the accusations the many
accusations of Fraud and pathology
leveled against Ellen White both during
and after her lifetime will they stand
up to historical and psychological
scrutiny uh I I think I'm about the only
Adventist critic who has the historical
credentials and the psychological
credentials to address that question
and um I've addressed it very
specifically the notion that I need to
be including all kinds of garbage that
Tim wants me to include in that
book um is just nonsense it shows that
he does doesn't understand research he
doesn't understand a research
question um you know he doesn't
understand what a psychobiography is all
that stuff was explained in my book I
can only assume that he didn't read the
book or that he doesn't grasp things
very well but um you know it's just
really sad that he makes all
these accusations while he you know goes
off on the self-righteous trip about how
we need to be so careful about judging
people's motives and then in his book
review of my psych biography he goes
right after saying that judges my
motives and and
one one context after another that
that's just absolutely humorous I don't
know if he's trying to be a comedian or
you know and and he's not he's not a a
valid scholar because when I tried to
respond to his book review it wasn't
allowed the white State wouldn't allow
me to respond just like Spectrum would
not allow me to respond to Jonathan
Butler's review so uh I put appendixes
and both my both of those reviews in the
uh White estate fraud appendix three and
four are my responses to Butler and to
Tim because um they're very easy to
respond to and I think the reason
Spectrum didn't want to publish it is
because it made Butler look so
embarrassed you know it basically just
embarrassed him by I went Point by Point
through his uh review and just took it
apart and I did the same thing with Tim
I mean these people are at at hominum
attacks that's all it is they don't look
at the research they don't look at the
source
documentation they don't look at the
lifelong patterns that Ellen White
reveals herself it's not me uh just
making accusations against her it's
herself saying these things she's the
one that says in 1849 sell your homes
God has shown me to sell your homes and
give the money to the cause which her
and James controlled her and James
became wealthy from that money they
never attempted to sell or downsize
their own home for the next seven years
as she was repeatedly making this call
to church members it it's just gross
exploitation I mean the stuff she was
doing any person who would look at it
objectively would say holy Toledo this
woman is evil
and um for these Scholars to try to act
like their objective researchers when
they just ignore all this evidence
that's so
damning um you know to me just
disqualifies them as Scholars they're
not Scholars at all um they're simply
Pretenders they want to keep their
status folks if you've seen the Ellen
White Funeral stream that we did um from
some months back I think it's almost up
to 15,000 views um you know that what
Steve is saying here we've looked at
these quotes directly um we've shown
that they've never addressed this
problem that is exactly what she did
we're going to be rehashing this quote
again on Monday when we talk about the
144,000 um but this idea of sell your
homes Christ is coming back you're not
going to need any of that stuff give it
to the church um you know so it can be
used to further the cause yet they never
did did that right they reaped the
benefits of it um and they got a big
windfall out of it um so we'll be
getting back into that on Monday as well
now his next claim is a little bit long
but it's all in the same vein of the
single charge he's making so I'll read
it all and then I want to get your
thoughts for those that want to read it
for themselves by the way all of these
quotes the link to this is in the
description box down below so if you
want you can follow along that way but
notice what he says he says quot
the author talking about you claims to
have used 325 references uh Mr Tim it's
actually
326 throughout his throughout his book
such a prolific number can be a strength
if the presuppositions are well in place
and the sources fairly reflect the
available data otherwise get this it
becomes just another way of impressing
The Not So well-informed
reader un fortunately Dy is very
selective in the use of sources placing
much emphasis on those that confirm his
views and simply ignoring those that
disagree with him for example Francis D
niichel their favorite hero classic uh
Francis D nickols Classic Len White and
her critics is referred to just once but
as a famous apologist work with biased
information several more uh several more
recent books that respond to the very
same issues raised by daily are not even
critically
mentioned the insightful LG white issue
Symposium series published yearly since
2005 by the center for Advent research
or Adventist research at Andrews
University is completely ignored more
surprising is the fact that the
outstanding LG white encyclopedia from
2013 considered the most important
reference work produced by the sth
Adventist Church in a half century is
mentioned just once amongst other
sources in an end note one would not
expect daily to quote all these sources
or to necessarily agree with their
perspectives but to Simply ignore them
throughout the book suggests a bias
especially from someone who considers
himself a specialist in Ellen White
similar omissions with inaccuracies can
be directed in or be detected in the way
Steve Daly handles primary sources for
example after suggesting that white fled
to Australia largely because of her
problem with plagiarism he states that
on March 20 1889 the first public charge
or accusation of plagiarism against
Ellen White to appear in the Press was
published in the heroldsberg Enterprise
and that it was a five-page article Daly
refers to this as the first public
charge without mentioning that it was DM
canri who was the mentor of all of these
charges which he had already raised in
his lectures in the trits theater
heroldsberg or Hillsburg Cali California
in 1889 and which were already being
advocated by him and the pastors Union
of Hillsburg in that
newspaper the March 20 article was
merely another short article signed by
the pastor Union and more how could that
two column article become a five-page
article if the newspaper had only four
pages nor should we Overlook the fact
that almost two years earlier in 1887
canri had already raised similar public
accusations in the Michigan Christian
Advocate this lack of historical
precision and historical reliability
clouds much of DA's research close quote
so again I know that was a lot but Steve
according to the associate director of
the Adventist biblical Research
Institute you are a remedial historian
who omits and selectively cites sources
with bias your astronomical amount of
citations in the LG White
psychobiography graphy not going to
actually address any of those they're
only convincing for the ignorant and
uninformed and like Jud Lake asserted
you are a canright parrot but don't
actually give him credit for it so
besides the massive case of projection
coming from Mr Tim regarding selectively
citing sources how accurate is that
charge again um it it overlaps with what
I just said when a person isn't
intelligent enough to understand what
research question is that's specifically
described in a book and followed to a te
and then he criticizes me for not
quoting the encyclopedia enough not
referring to the Symposium all those
things are irrelevant to my research
question uh it's like this guy's not
very bright does he not understand what
my research question was does he not
understand that I followed that research
question to a te he tries to use one
source and by that one reference tries
to discredit all my references and what
he's doing there is he's straining at a
Nat and swallowing a camel first of all
he's making a false claim that canright
somehow planted this story in the
newspaper you know this is a secular
newspaper my point was this was the
first time a secular newspaper came out
and took the position that Ellen White
was a
plist uh and it was a five-part article
it was in five different um newspapers
over five weeks I I meant to say
five-part article and it went in five
page article and that kind of thing
doesn't get caught easily by U you know
editors and stuff so um it was a
five-part article that stretched over
five issues of the Hillsburg Enterprise
and there were two of them in um
February and three of them consecutively
in March and you know what he's trying
to do there is nitpick on a on a word
basically and then try to discredit all
my research in the book based on that
one stupid point it's called straining
in a Nat and swallowing a camel and
while he's doing it he's misrepresent
presenting the newspaper they vetted
that story uh there was a whole group of
ministers who'd been hearing canr and uh
believed and accepted what he said and
the newspaper not only acknowledged that
they uh recognized that Ellen White was
a plist but the newspaper itself was
taking the position that Ellen White was
a plist and Tim seems to want to give
the impression that the newspaper didn't
vet this at all they just let right come
in and write his own story in the paper
or something it's absolute nonsense plus
when we recognize that it's 100% true
that she was a plist and they gave
examples of it in the
stories you know I I just have very
little patience for the kind of
dishonesty that uh Tim is doing there I
would love to debate Tim um any time in
a objective uh environment with a
neutral moderat
because the guy clearly doesn't know his
stuff um you know he he acts like I
should be uh talking about FD nickel all
the time FD nickel was a farce you know
FD nickel was the apologist of all
apologists FD nickel was completely
dishonest in how he covered the shut
door issues as we were talking about
earlier he takes her later statements
and makes a big deal of them as if the
secondary
uh statements that come in 73 and ' 84
are more valid than the actual statement
she makes between 1844 and
1851 this is just absolute nonsense and
uh you know nickel was a smart guy I'll
give him credit for that he was a lot
smarter than Arthur white and he uh
mentored Arthur white but Arthur white
was never a student he was never a
historian he was a pretender all the way
niichel was a smart guy
uh he was involved with the debates in
the 1920s on creation and evolution and
uh presented himself quite well he he
became the young Superstar of adventism
and then he became the ultimate
apologist uh the ultimate answer man for
anyone who ever dared to critic you know
criticize Ellen White but he's dishonest
he's like a very smart lawyer who knows
how to twist things and deceive people
you know lawyers are paid they're
expected to do everything they can to
win a case for their client but
researchers are not expected to do that
they're not expected to twist the
evidence they're not expected to leave
out the most important Source
documentation while you take later
statements that are the exact opposite
of what the original statements were and
you try to build your whole case on the
later
statements it's just your responsible
and it's incompetent so I don't want to
uh spend a bunch of time um with nickel
when he's already discredited himself on
the most important issue really which
was the shut door and he wrote hundreds
of pages I mean it's not like he
addressed this in a few pages it was
more than a hundred pages in his three
major apologetic Works where he just
went into this shut door thing in
immense de detail leaving out all the
most important quotes I mean how stupid
can you be that's just it's really
difficult to tolerate and Tim doesn't
seem to know any better you know
he's It's just sad that uh he's repres
of course the white State who takes it
seriously they've always been the
ultimate apologetic body and that's all
Tim is an apologist I would expect more
from a butler that's why I was more
disappointed by his book review because
he should know better you know but um
but I don't take someone like Tim very
seriously or the white State very
seriously well it's interesting because
you point out something that I think is
a common problem that I even see in my
videos from at what you'd consider
Adventist leoty um at least based on
their their comments and that is that
sdas will often comment on my videos um
something that has nothing to do with
the topic of the video and ask well why
didn't you address this right well
because videos especially in in in
content creation World um and this is
typically in short format content
because we do long format content on
this platform as well um but on the
short format content you know there's a
thesis behind the video it's to address
a specific point it's not it's not to
address everything every possible thing
you could possibly answer it's a
specific point but they love to ignore
that point and say well over here you
didn't address this and FD nickel is
even to this day as I'm sure you're
aware um he's their go-to guy right they
still they love to especially when it
comes to the Ellen White racism for
example which we're going to look at um
some comments regarding FD nickel later
but Steve he continues he also mentions
your charge regarding Ellen White's
plagiarism uh as they love to try and
frame it uh her thought Gems or literary
borrowing that's the term Jud Lake likes
to use in his book um to kind of soften
this IDE idea that no you're stealing
you're stealing it doesn't matter if it
was legal at the time if it was illegal
um that's always a fun thing to get into
it with him so God's law which you guys
are champions of it only is really
relevant if the American government
recognizes when it is is is is correct
because if it doesn't transcend that um
well then what Ellen White did
regardless of whether it was legal or
common or not was still theft but notice
what he says here um he
continues and he says quote
one of the most recurrent themes of the
book is white as a
plagiarist after qualifying her as the
most successful plagiarist and con
artist of all time he asserts the
reality was that if proper attribution
had occurred there would have been
nothing significant contributed by the
author Ellen was taking virtually all of
her history theology thoughts and other
content from other authors without
attribution for the sake of record in
1986 the LG white estate produced an
important document entitled Ellen
White's literary sources how much
borrowing is
there this document has been updated
over the years to reflect known literary
borrowings by white identified by both
her supporters and her
critics this document demonstrates a
much lower percentage of borrowing than
Steve Daly
claims his conclusions do not reflect
the latest available research on the
question close quote so Steve now he
claims your charges uh your charges of
plagiarism have already been dealt with
by the white estate and obviously unbias
source of course yes and that document
proves that your claims are blown out of
proportion is this true it's funny
because Warren John's worked for the
white estate he was one of their
attorneys and he said she plagiarized
everything in every book I mean he was
quoted as saying her plagiarism is so
extensive that he he's not aware of any
book where it wasn't uh prolific and um
you know I think Olsen and gyel and the
they were a little more honest Tim seems
to be back in the old school of Arthur
white or something but um you
know all we have to do is look at the
velopment study you know that's the most
concentrated study of a relatively small
amount of material over eight years he
was paid by the church to do it I know
veltman well he was one of my professors
when I was at pu and I was amazed the
church chose him because this guy is a
man of integrity and uh that's you never
expect the church to choose a man of
integrity to do something like that and
of course they didn't like his
conclusion iions that's why the study
wasn't given out to the church it was
just summarized in Ministry magazine
after eight years of a lot of money and
a lot of uh time and energy but U what
does welman say you know he says 31% of
what he studied uh could be directly
tied to plagarism
directly tied to copying specifically
from other authors and he said of course
we we didn't have unlimited resources so
there could have been an awful lot of
resources that we weren't aware of that
she copied from but 31% significant but
the two Mo much more important things
that he concluded which Tim never
mentions of course he doesn't even
mention veltman here but um you know
number one veltman concluded that her
work was derivative not
original this was a general description
of her stuff it was derivative not from
God but from other authors so even
though she didn't word for word copy a
lot of things we know that she got her
outlines her T subtitles titles her
themes all these were taken from other
books she was not an original thinker
she wants to give the impression that
God's giving her all this stuff but we
know that wasn't the case and veltman
even as a more sobering conclusion
which troubled him more than anything
else was her
immorality implied in what she did that
she deliberately hid these things this
coping and plagarism from her assistance
she tried to disguise it in her
manuscripts and um you know as Fanny and
Maran found out more and more what was
really going on they were absolutely
horrified that they were being made
party to this kind of illegal unethical
immoral behavior and this is a prophet
supposedly a prophet of God doing all
this stuff you know it's really sad um I
I didn't really answer the the other
question about my earlier statements you
know I was never a big Ellen White fan
even when I was a kid my dad said uh you
know don't don't take her stuff too
seriously
she says a lot of things where she
didn't know what she was talking about
so he was kind of a man ahead of his
time but um but he wasn't a theologian
or anything so he just uh he was a a
very critical thinker and smart person
and so he did at least plant the idea in
my head of testing her stuff when I was
young and then um you know when I went
into the Adventist Ministry I did so to
try to change the church move the church
in a much more healthy direction for
young people that was my goal but um you
know the more I studied and learned
about Ellen White where I became a
historian and really looked at things in
detail um and started teaching Adventist
history um you know I recognized that
this woman had a lot of problems but I
didn't really conclude that she was a
absolute false prophet till I wrote my
books uh the prophetic Rift 1 and two
and I was still in adventism at the time
and I knew I wouldn't be in adventism
long after writing those books but um
you know those were written in 208 and
209 but I was teaching in my Adventist
history classes even through the 90s
about the shut door and Ellen White's uh
flipflops on the shut door and so before
I really got into the shut door I was
inclined to give Ellen the benefit of
the doubt but once I became aware of her
dishonesty with regard to the shut
door um I never quoted her and I was
never like Ray I was never a Ellen White
fan I never used her in my sermons or
based my sermons on her anything like
that
so you know it's just a basic evolution
of uh study and thought and and
recognition over the years more and more
and more uh that Ellen White had more
and more and more problems but it wasn't
until I examined the specific research
question about her
pathology and her uh fraud uh with all
the critics that I really became deeply
aware of how sick this woman was that's
when I decided to write the
psychobiography as I I saw the evidence
that holy Toledo this is this is not a
Well Woman This is a woman who's a
sociopath and very specifically U you
know without diagnosing her just looking
at the historical evidence in comparing
it to uh diagnostic criteria she's a
high functioning sociopath and a
narcissist and a number of things and
you know I'm I'm the first psychologist
to
study her as a historian and conclude
about her mental illness and
stuff yeah it's you know it's
interesting because I feel like in my
experience in adventism and maybe this
was the same for you I felt like there
was a a really big uh negative emphasis
on critical thinking absolutely um and
sort of or or I guess compartmentalized
critical thinking um it's only you're
only allowed to critically think in in
certain areas and he makes this claim
you know that they've made for I don't
know how long now um and they still make
it to this day their apolog just still
make it to this day um we've dealt with
all those criticisms you know it's
already all been dealt with way back
when don't even listen to these people
that's the sort of mentality but when
you go check out what it is they're
claiming which it's almost a sense of
irony because there's a lot of
projection going on here as we're going
to see a little bit later folks um I
don't think they've actually read the
critics as well as they want us to read
the pro apologist like FD nickel because
when you go and actually check out the
things that they're claiming that have
silenced all of this stuff it doesn't
deal with the issues absolutely like I
said I'm back in Jed Lake's book here
recently prepping for some content and
revisiting this and I'm just reminded of
how the claim is this has already been
dealt with this has all been dealt with
Etc no it hasn't because when you go to
these Works they're not even dealing
with the primary issue they're obus
skating to some other thing they're
they're saying well well no no over here
you know you hear the classic well she
said this over here and look how flowery
and uplifting it is yeah well so did
Joseph Smith so good sociopath does yeah
so does the parking lot Prophet down at
the local church who had whatever to say
that has no bearing on the fact that she
claimed for example this is just one of
many like you mentioned earlier over
seven times over seven times she claimed
to be shown the day and the hour of
Christ's return why is God such a lousy
Communicator yeah hello she's claiming
this came from God she's claiming that
God told her the day and the hour the
defense I've heard recently Steve is no
no no after she said that she claimed
that she didn't actually remember the
day and the hour yeah right so God
wanted to tell tell her the day and the
hour but he's omniscient and knew that
she wasn't going to remember the day and
the hour and she was going to go tell a
bunch of people she knew the day in the
hour but didn't remember the day in the
hour in the vision she writes that she
was given the day in the hour but then
she later said it just it's terrible
defenses it doesn't actually deal with
the actual issue but later in the paper
this is now what he asserts this is his
next Claim about
you he says quote these the issues
raised by daily in his book and here he
speaks about your Ellen White
psychobiography are not new and have
been addressed in previous
Publications even so it might be
interesting to more closely compare the
outof adventism spiritual journeys of
both canr and daily paralleling can
right's the life of Ellen G white from
1919 and DA's Ellen White a
psychobiography and exploring their
levels of historical reliability and
rhetorical techniques but such
assessment should always be ethically
and legally responsible the irony taking
into consideration Christ's warning
against judging the inner motives of
others Matthew
71 close quote so after doing the exact
thing that he warns against here judging
the inner motives of someone he claims
that all your objections and all of your
books are recycled nothing new and again
makes a parallel to you and canri giving
the under Tes that you're simply a
canright parrent Steve how accurate is
this again you know it just speaks for
itself that this guy doesn't even have
good reasoning Powers much less
scholarly uh understanding um I I I
really feel sorry for him that he's
embarrassing himself because uh when you
don't even understand what a research
question is and you go off the way he
has failing to recognize that I followed
my research question to a te you just
come out looking like a fool I mean any
researcher as a licensed psychologist I
was trained in research and research
methods and statistics and these kinds
of things at Great depth much more so
than this guy has any clue about and yet
he's trying to uh criticize my research
I'll be glad to put up my academic
research against whatever he's done
anytime
anywhere um you know Tim is
just what you would expect from the
whest state um you know that's about all
I can say the white state is the
ultimate apologetic entity and their
whole purpose is to defend and to
perpetuate Ellen and um so there's no
objectivity there it for him to try to
uh challenge my
objectivity you know I have no acts to
grind I I didn't leave adventism
angry um I enjoyed my years in adventism
uh it was a great part of my life uh I
enjoyed it more when I left adventism
and went to work for UCLA and got out of
the Adventist
subculture in the ghetto but um but I
didn't have any kind of ACC to grind
against adventism um like any adven
employee they tried to control me and
you know that's just the the whole
reason that they use this argument that
uh oh we've dealt with all this stuff
this is old old garbage you know they're
appealing to the authoritarian mentality
in adventism adventism attracts people
who are conformists it attracts people
who
lend themselves to an authoritarian
personality and uh that's exactly what
they're exploiting and taking advantage
of here oh we're the authority figures
and we're going to assure you that uh
there's nothing new nothing to see here
don't mind that person behind the
curtain there um you know it's all just
completely obvious what they're doing
and they're running into more and more
problems because the internet more and
more people are able to run down more
and more
information and uh the church is in
trouble uh their old methods are not
going to continue to stand up and the
younger Generations not buying it and uh
they've got a lot of problems on their
plate and so they want to scapegoat
Someone Like Me by ad homing them
attacks but it's just absolute nonsense
well Steve the reason I I there's a lot
of claims he makes in this paper I only
picked about seven of them or so and the
reason that one stuck out to me is
because just before this statement in
the paper we shouldn't judge the motives
of another individual Matthew 71 you
know insert the proof text in there he
recognizes your stated position for
writing your book and notice what he
claims quote in his book LG white a
psycho graphy daily leaves aside both
the reliability of a historian and the
ethical stand of a psychologist to
become utterly judgmental of the already
long deceased white reading this book
the most natural assumption would be
that it was produced out of spite or
bitterness against the Adventist Church
even though the author emphatically
denies it yet such a denial becomes
doubtful in light of the repeated and
strong anti- Ellen White and anti-
adventism spirit that permeates the
whole book it is noteworthy that the
author even subtly tries to transfer to
God his own responsibility for the
publication of his book he says I have
prayed that if my own attempt at
psychobiography provides in this book uh
uh uh sorry I have prayed that if my own
attempt at psychobiography provides in
this book will do more harm than good
God will not allow it to be completed or
published so the reader is induced to
believe that since God did not stop its
publication he actually approves of it
close quote that sounds to me like
judging the inner motives of an other
absolutely I
mean all over the place there despite
his claim to the contrary and warning
against such and apparently one isn't
allowed to critically examine Ellen
White because she's deceased and one
can't pray over writing a book of this
kind of a serious nature because that's
gross manipulation of people I mean when
you start criticizing a person's
prayers um you know I I think it's just
pure projection the white estate knows
the kind of manipulation they engage in
constantly with church members so
they're simply projecting that onto me
but
um I I well that leads perfectly to my
NE my question with that quote which is
is that what you meant in the book
because I have the book I've read the
book and I I know what he's referencing
is that what you meant when you said you
prayed over writing the book no I'm just
simply saying this was a serious topic
so I prayed over it it's that simple I
mean I didn't want the book published if
if God didn't want it published I'm
agreeing with God lord uh
I don't want this book to be published
this isn't for my ego I don't make money
off my
books despite all the false accusations
of Adventist who don't know what they're
talking about um I simply want to pursue
truth I'm trying to present truth as
best I can um if I'm somehow deluded or
or am not seeing truth is I think I am I
want you to intervene so the book
doesn't do harm
um I mean it's just a serious honest
prayer I for to to criticize a person's
prayer life when you're talking about
not judging motives is about as
revolting as you can get you know this
guy he he just repeatedly makes false
accusations he he started out his book
review by saying I was fired when I
wasn't fired I mean the guy make makes
no attempt to do any kind of research
before he makes statements while he's
self-righteously acting like he doesn't
judge and he doesn't um try to determine
people's motives and then he does the
exact opposite of what he's warning
against you know so I I really have very
little respect for him I you know it's
so funny that he's talking about ethics
and morality when he's with the widest
State that's been shown to be absolutely
Thief
Liars coverups for Arthur white I mean
this guy needs to be talking about what
the white estate's going to do now that
the evidence is out on Arthur white what
are they going to do about that what are
they going to do about the six volumes
of Ellen White's life that were written
by a man who was an absolute thief and
liar and and hidden you know hid his
role in creating this fabrication
which he knew was a fabrication I mean
the white state is so implicated in this
that um this guy should spend all of his
time just trying to figure out what to
say to that rather than making up lies
about me yeah I'll tell you what they're
going to do they're going to get their
shovels they're going to dig a big hole
and try and bury that with this the same
tactic and method that they've used for
I don't know how long but the thing they
don't understand in folks I've brought
this up many times on this channel um
their old tactics are not going to work
anymore right this isn't 1980 anymore
this is a a a different era so if you're
just joining me folks I have Steve Daly
here Steve is a former um professor in
SDA institutions he has his doctorate in
Psychology um he left the SDA Church
some years ago and we are discussing um
a number of claims that the SDA Church
uh by way of her Scholars have made
about her um and we are going to be
transitioning here shortly into um some
of the claims from his book um after we
address their sort of defenses to a
number of those claims so Steve I got
one more here he concludes his article
by saying
this
quote throughout the book again
referring to your psychobiography of
Ellen White there is a pervasive
negative and even destructive Spirit
towards White that is voiced in a rather
t uh T tendentious and biased manner
even conflicting ideas and Concepts
should be discussed without becoming so
judgmental unfortunately that is not the
case in this book furthermore there is a
repeated pattern discernable where
historical evidence is not accurately
dealt with or opposing pos position or
opinions and alternative interpretations
are not fairly presented or even listed
this is not good scholarship and puts a
dark shadow Over The credibility of the
entire book in this sense the book by
Steve Daly reflects not the truth about
Ellen White but rather the truthiness of
his thinking close
quote that's what he concludes his
article with so this is their standard
hitandrun method to detour Adventist
from even considering reading your books
yeah the same sort of spirit and tactic
that they've manifested from the days of
canr a form of poisoning the well if you
will he ends up reiterating that your
scholarship is not good and it casts a
dark shadow over your
credibility so what would you like to
say in response to that before we get
into exploring the big lies uh that you
talk about in your
book again I would just say I'm glad to
put my works and my particularly my
academic works up against his any time
and we'll see who's the scholar we'll
see who's uh the research
we'll see who's objective and who isn't
um you know he is basically just echoing
what he wrote In the book review there
that's the exact same way he ended the
book review and stuff but uh you know
when you don't allow a fellow scholar if
you're if he's calling himself a scholar
if you don't allow someone to respond to
a book review you write that's uh not
scholar ship you know that that's just
censorship it's a complete inability to
be fair and anything else he says um you
know amounts to a hill of beans because
he won't even allow me to respond to a
book review he writes about my book I
mean that's just completely ridiculous
and it it's typical of the white State
they don't want anyone to read anything
that could possibly interfere with their
propaganda they're they're nothing but a
propaganda machine and Tim is nothing
but a propagandist he's not a scholar
he's not uh you know he he won't come on
and debate me because he knows he
doesn't stand a chance um you know the
bottom line is that uh this hitandrun
approach of just using ad hominum
attacks that are completely untrue not
addressing the evidence um it's just one
thing after the next that is an
embarrassment to these people but
they're all they're trying to do is
deceive the masses to continue to
deceive the masses they don't care what
methods they have to use to deceive the
masses they just want to deceive as as
much of the massive SDA audience that
they possibly can and uh they'll use any
liee to do it they'll use any uh well
all we have to do is look at Arthur
white look at what he did with Carrie
Johnson to perpetuate the myth and lie
of Ellen White I mean you can't get any
lower than that to completely fabricate
a book claim to be someone's secretary
when you never met them Arthur white
knew the whole thing that's why it took
him 20
years because he more and more and more
he found out more and more that gri
Johnson was just a pathological serial
liar that's all she was and so he was so
invested in wanting to get the goods on
canr right that he became the same kind
of Serial liar and deceiver and Thief
that she was and um you know you don't
become that you're you either are that
or you're not so he was that he he fell
from the same tree that Ellen White was
from and um they were both extremely
dishonest deceitful people and the
whitest state in general falls into that
category they're covering up they're
Liars they're do and say anything to uh
deceive the masses about Ellen White and
it's all about money all about their
power their position it it's just very
sad you know uh when you look at
motivation
um he's the one who has all the
motivations to lie not
me yeah so let's transition now to the
big lies which is how you you brand them
in your psychobiography as well as your
uh your your most recent book toward the
beginning of the book you talk about
Ellen White's big lie her lie
specifically what is that big lie
and who all was involved in covering it
up I mean the biggest lie if you're just
going to choose the one big lie of Ellen
White is that she was the instrument of
God that everything she wrote was
downloaded by the almighty you know uh I
have the 27 quotes of her claims and
that's number one that she doesn't write
a single thing to the church that
doesn't come directly from the Throne of
God I mean that it is such a ridiculous
lie and such a big lie that everything
else all the other lies she tells are
based on that
lie um and that false Authority that she
claims God gave her and then to top it
off she acts like she's this humble
vessel of clay that could do nothing of
herself it's only if God uh lifts her up
and speaks through her that she can do
anything so everything is about how God
is just speaking through her she
basically claims to be the voice of God
she claims to be the spirit of Prophecy
she calls herself that that is a term
reserved for God the spirit of Prophecy
is the testimony of Jesus
himself uh to call yourself the spirit
of Prophecy is simple blasphemy that
Adventists can't understand this and
from my very earliest years writing in
adventism I 100% oppose that I 100%
oppose this Remnant lie um so even in my
earliest years if Tim wants to say I did
some great about Fai he can try to claim
that lie but anyone who studies my
writings over my lifetime will see very
early from the very beginning of my work
work as an Adventist Minister I was 100%
critical of Adventist claims of the
remnant of Ellen's claims of being the
spirit of Prophecy Adventist claim that
was a mark of the remnant church it's
just disgusting I mean those were the
things I was trying to change while I
was in adventism and you know more and
more and more I just found how
completely impossible it was to change a
lot of these
things yeah
um you kind of drill in on it more um
Ellen White's big lie specifically
toward the beginning of the book um on
page 15 you say this
quote after all the false date setting
for the second coming of Christ that
Ellen had engaged in based on supposed
Visions she still managed to insist that
Christ was going to return on October
22nd 1851 so Joseph bates's seven-year
Theory this was the basis of her final
shut door testimonies listed above which
you listed in the book when that date
also passed in the future James and
Ellen delegated her shutd door Visions
from their writings and in the future
Ellen would deny ever having such
Visions the major problem with Ellen
White's claimed Visions was that she
attributed their content to God so the
big lie that Ellen White was telling
became the big lie that God was telling
close
quote now in response to this claim even
though his paper was written before the
release of his book Alberto Tim had this
defense in his paper and I'm curious to
hear your thoughts this will be our
final thoughts from Alberto
Tim he writes quote surprising as it may
sound Dy has no difficulty in making
Ellen White to Advocate exactly what she
was
condemning in 1850 Joseph Bates
published a 16-page pamphlet entitled an
explanation of the typical and
antitypical Sanctuary by the scriptures
suggesting that Christ would return 7
years after
1844 that is in October
1851 in November 1850 white warned the
Lord showed me that time had not been a
test since 1844 and that time will never
again be a
test in July 1851 she stated in the same
tone the Lord has shown me that the
message of the third angel must go and
that it should not be hung on time for
time will never be a test again I saw
there were some that were making
everything Bend to the time of the uh of
this next fall that is making their
calculations in reference to that time
nonetheless Dy repeatedly speaks of
white as the great promoter of this
Theory and even as having been
shamefully disappointment by it now
that's his uh own spelling there but
close quote so Steve he claims that
Ellen White before
1851 claimed that time would never again
be a test which proves that she never
endorsed any more dates by vision and
this proves that you're supposedly
omitting this fact and are in error when
you claim this is that
true absolutely not you know I don't
know if Tim is just completely super
icial in his understanding of things or
again if he's being deliberately
dishonest it's always hard to tell with
the apologist but when you look at all
the quotes starting with the
1844 uh Joseph Turner plagarism and you
just go through all of them uh what you
find and and certainly uh you know
Joseph Bates didn't come up with his um
seven-year Theory till towards the end
of that seven-year period it was 48 I
believe when when he wrote the paper and
Ellen endorsed it and James was less
convinced by it which is very
interesting because in even as early as
1849 James was wanting
to you know broaden out more do more
Mission types of things but Ellen was
convinced by Bates that the seven-year
theory was
correct and um you know these two
statements that he quotes are um
have to be understood in the context of
everything else she says Ellen
contradicts herself quite often so the
fact that she contradicts herself isn't
terribly surprising but uh in June uh 27
of
1850 which is uh you know recorded in
early writings page 67 Ellen gives a
very specific time prophecy that the the
newcomers to their movement and there
were only a small number of them but the
newcomers who had joined them only had
three months only a few months left
before probation
closes um you know she this is obviously
tied to the seven-year Theory when you
read what she writes in early writings
it's all about this terrible time of
trouble that's coming probation's going
to close before the time of trouble
starts every sin has to be dealt with
you have to be sin you won't have an
intercessor um you know the this
statement that they only had a few
months left a few that means three
typically uh she she's being very
specific there they only have a few
months left before it enters this final
period where probation will be closed
they won't have any opportunities after
that this is in June of 1850 that she
writes this so why would she write this
other thing in November well one very
obvious reason would be that uh things
weren't materializing the way she had
prophesied uh they only had a few months
in June June July August September at
the latest uh but there was no close of
probation that was perceivable there was
no great time of trouble that was could
be perceived in any way shape or form so
now she's getting a little worried hey
why isn't any of my stuff coming true
which was typical of her stuff uh none
of that stuff and during her seven-year
period ever seemed to come true you know
she got it in the language of Canan or
whatever but um you know so she's kind
of protecting herself a little bit here
with this November comment but she still
goes back to uh you know damning
everyone the shut door is still on uh as
late as June of
1851 she makes her last shut door
pronouncement that the whole world is
lost uh that no one can be saved from
this point forward who has not already
been saved going back to her uh
pre-tribulation pre-time of trouble
perspective and uh and then it's after
that uh and I think it was a combination
of a bunch of things now it's almost uh
October it's obvious that none of the
stuff she's prophesied is even close to
coming true there's no time of trouble
there's no persecution against Adventist
there's none of this stuff that she
claimed would happen so what does she do
she makes this myopa but it's not a
myopa she's not admitting she was wrong
she's not admitting that she didn't get
any of this stuff from God she just
makes a statement to try to protect
herself when October 22 Comes This is
like a last
minute effort to try to salvage yourself
and I'm sure James had a lot to do with
it he was probably saying I told you you
shouldn't have bought that stupid
seven-year Theory and you know he he
didn't buy it and so now she's having to
claim that God gave it to her but she
has to try to discredit it somehow I
mean this is just Tim doesn't understand
the complexity here or he's deliberate
ly lying I don't know which it is but if
you look at the complexity of it it's
very clear what's going on it's very
clear that Ellen White was deceiving
lying trying to cover for herself uh
double speaking speaking out of both
sides of her mouth so that whatever
happened in October 22 she could claim
oh yes I predicted that um you know it's
just typical L and white is what it is
you know Steve I I wonder if Ellen
accepting the seven-year theory is what
resulted in James having to sleep in a
different room um I I know that maybe
that was the Catalyst or the snowball
that led to the the marital dysfunction
um which maybe we'll save that
discussion for another time Jud Lake
actually has some interesting defenses
on uh on that front but Tim's Tim's
claim here really just shows the bias
they themselves have that they claim
everyone critical of the movement has um
like you mentioned in your book uh that
he even criticizes anyone without a
commitment to adventism that examines
the
evidence it's just not defensible folks
it's just it's not defensible um any
person without a dog in the fight if you
showed them these things they're G to be
able to tell you um I would go so far as
to say like an eight-year-old would be
able to tell you H I don't know it just
goes against common sense you know it
just if it if it you know Walks Like A
Duck quacks like a duck okay but we've
heard his name mentioned several times
so question for
you Steve who was DM canr and why has
the SDA Church sought to destroy him
because in chapter two of your book you
get into the threat of DM canr to the
SDA church so can you go into that some
for the audience yeah just a brief
summary um you know canri didn't grew up
in a religious home his dad wasn't
religious his previous ancestors had
been but he grew up on a farm his dad
was civic-minded he was a great uh
Community person but he wasn't educated
he wasn't high on education canri had a
real hunger for Education he paid for
his own
education um took trains paid for
everything uh in spite of the fact that
his father wasn't n supportive of it and
he had no religious background until he
uh came across some Baptist uh as he was
approaching uh I think 18 years old at
the time and um they uh helped him uh
you know understand the gospel and
accept the gospel and he was quite
excited about that um he had a real
passion for the things that they shared
with him but the next year he got trans
erred to an Adventist school because of
a relative living in New York it was I
believe and um so for the first time now
he was in an advent school and James and
Ellen uh this was back in the early days
of the movement 5,000 or less uh there
weren't that many people in the movement
and um so James and Ellen would go right
around to the schools and recruit they
were big on recruiting young people that
they felt had po potential and they saw
a lot of potential in canite so uh they
recruited him to live in their home and
work for them and they did the same
thing with his brother um they did the
same thing with his wife uh luria she
was in the white home uh she didn't live
with them quite the same way that canri
did for the period but she was there a
lot and Ellen kind of adopted her as a
daughter so uh they saw the inside of
the wh's life you know the marital stuff
the the uh like um you know canri
describes he saw them take all these old
books that were worthless that they
owned and come up with the idea that hey
we can get a bunch of money for these by
forcing the church to buy these books
from us and send them out free to the
mission field and all this kind of stuff
so they came up with this uh clever plan
to to take all these worthless books
that no one wanted and forc the church
to buy them and of course Ellen had
visions that God was telling every
member to uh support this work and buy
these books well they're personally
paying the whites for these books and
canri saw this whole thing and that was
kind of one of the early things that
really put questions in his mind along
with the hypocrisy on diet and you know
Ellen and James Downing the 200 PB
Porker when she's writing her health
message that everyone's to be strict
vegetarian and you know it's he sees all
the
hypocrisy and uh and yet he he has a lot
of cognitive dissonance because the
whites have helped him they've gotten
him into the ministry he's a a favorite
son he's given opportunities that uh the
white alone whites alone were able to
give people so he shot right up the
ranks of evanst ministers so he owed a
lot to the whites and at the same time
he saw the hypocrisy he saw the lies he
saw
the financial dishonesty he you know
James was accused of embezzling from the
church way back early on you know the
messenger party Etc left the church over
Ellen's false prophets false prophecies
and the shut door and the uh James
embezzling money from the church and
Ellen was part of that but uh you know
canr had this real double whammy going
on where uh adventism was everything it
was his whole identity it was his career
it was his life uh his wife was tied to
it they were all tied to the whites and
then uh they were seeing more and more
of this very troubling stuff that said
how can this be a prophet of God you
know this is just very troubling because
they were sincere honest Believers and
not con artists the way the whites were
and uh so then you know when they
vacation with them and and Ellen wrote
the 25 Page Letter condemning them after
James and and can right had a blow up
um you know they at that point they
realized holy Toledo You Know This
Woman's just she just makes stuff up and
ATT tribute to God and it it comes out
of a blowup so she immediately has God
downloading a 25 Page Letter which she
claims he showed her all this stuff way
earlier but now he was telling her to
write it yeah right um you know it's uh
the bottom line is canri knew way more
about Ellen her personal life than any
other critic of of Ellen White by far
you know he was living right in their
home he saw everything first stand he
was also a brilliant guy he was the one
who represented Adventist in all the
major debates uh when they went up
against miles Grant anyone could have
done that could have been James White
could have been uh lboro could have been
any of them they all selected canright
canright was the one who was considered
to be the best defender he knew
Adventist theology better than any other
person and James wasn't even a student
you know he he stole the stuff from the
young guys and claimed it was his own as
can right documents but
uh you know the bottom line was all the
other churches knew can right because he
was the one that would debate against
them so this guy has a lot of H gravitas
he has a lot of credibility outside
adventism and inside adventism so uh
that's the reason he was say such a
incredible threat is he had all the
personal knowledge of James and Ellen he
witnessed it firsthand he wasn't relying
on rumors or secondhand information he
saw it
firsthand and he was also the spokesman
for Adventist teaching and Theology and
he understood it better than anyone else
in the church so when he came to realize
it's not the true gospel this isn't
really what the Bible teaches who's
going to be more threatening than the
person who represented the church to
defend them so uh he was definitely an
extreme threat you know there's there's
just absolutely no question about
that yeah and I mean as you're obviously
aware um that's not the picture that's
painted of canr in the SDA church for
sure um you're going to get this sort of
he's an arch heretic um he's a you know
a total backstabbing Judas type
individual um Benedict Arn yeah exactly
and you know the the thing that's so
interesting is has the SDA Church
utilized Alberto Tim's advice regarding
fairly representing canright the
criticisms he was just making against
you in that paper is he utilizing that
same standard when it comes to DM
canite no they're they're not are you
looking at all of the sources you know
he's saying that you know Steve daily in
his his book you know he may claim that
he has 326 sources but that's only going
to impress the uninformed individual um
the these sorts of statements um they're
not using their own standard that
they're claiming the critics of
adventism need to use when it comes to
their criticisms of of canite um you
mentioned a little bit there uh his
relationship to the the whites that's
another area that they've sort of tried
to rewrite history and twist the facts
and say well well this this man had an
axe to grind against the whites he was
uh you know he was angry at them Etc can
you speak into that a little bit more
what sort of relationship did he have
with the whites on a personal level he
cut the whites way more
slack people that try to say you know I
copy DM canr DM canright never called
Ellen White a fraud DM canr never called
Ellen White a con artist uh DM canr
never came close to criticizing the
lights the way I have uh and I base it
all on what they wrote what they said
their own source documentation but canri
loved these people you know he he wept
at her funeral uh that was one the one
thing that was true
that but uh you know all the other stuff
is just pure lies that he recanted that
he wanted back in that he said he was a
lost man all the stuff they throw at him
is a pure lie uh and and he wasn't an
angry person um he was the one that
wanted the truth when he left adventism
he was the one that said I'll never say
a word about adventus if you promise not
to attack me but they couldn't resist it
they brought all this on themselves and
you know back to Tim the guy is the
ultimate hypocrite because uh here he
accuses me of being biased not being
fair not using sources correctly when
I'm 100% true to my research question
but then he turns around and writes a
book review what is a book review
supposed to do it's supposed to be fair
to the entire book so his obligation as
a book Reviewer is to be fair to my
entire
psychobiography he doesn't even address
the main
sources and the main evidence which is
Source documented from her own pen her
own life her and James it's Source
documented stuff it's not me making
stuff up it's not me making accusations
apart from the absolute evidence I
mean it's just
unbelievable uh that he could be such a
hypocrite that when as a reviewer he was
a 100% failure on the very thing that he
accuses me of doing when they didn't
apply to me because I was true to my
research question it's just it's almost
mindboggling that a person could be so
hypocritical and think he could get away
with it it's just
ridiculous yeah um there's a lot I could
add obviously to that because again it
just that paper I'm I'm when I first
read it I'm thinking okay let's hear I
always start any sort of examination of
anything they put out whether it's Jud
lak's book it's Kevin Paulson at the ad
vindicate or whoever it may be I always
start with the thesis of okay what is
the criticism let's see where are you
addressing it where are you addressing
the criticism okay still waiting still
waiting still waiting and I got through
all six pages of Mr Tim's paper he
didn't address a single claim Steve that
you make in your book right you make
hundreds of claims in the book yet the
CLA the only defense I ever hear is
that's out of context okay show it
demonstrate it let's see it okay but
they don't want to touch that with a 10-
foot pole so it turns into this person's
angry this person's bitter this person
doesn't know what we actually believe
like they claim about canri if canri is
so was so uninformed about adventism he
knew nothing about adventism like you
mentioned why was he put forth as your
representative in public debate why were
you paying him to travel around on the
what they used to call Crusades going
around teaching adventism recruiting
people to adventism yet for some reason
when we leave adventism there's some
sort of I guess you didn't catch this
part about when the the when you signed
on the dotted line in your baptismal
vows in adventism Steve you didn't read
the fine print clear enough because
there was a clause in there that said
once you leave there's going to be an
undownload from all the information in
your brain and you're not going to
remember it anymore the things that you
were taught so anytime that you critique
adventism now it's because that
undownload has happened and you just
don't remember anything correctly um
it's just laughable it's laughable
that's not in defense deal with the
actual claims you document down this
quote from Ellen White regarding
canright she
writes quote God has been pleased to
open to me the secrets of the inner life
and the hidden sins of his people the
unpleasant Duty has been laid upon me to
reprove wrongs and to reveal hidden
sins when I have been compelled by the
spirit of God to reprove sins that
others did not know existed it is
stirred up the natural feelings in the
heart of the
unsanctified while some have humbled
their hearts before God and with
repentance and confession have forsaken
their sins others have felt a spirit of
hatred rise in their hearts their pride
has been hurt when their course has been
reproved they entertain the thought that
it is Sister white who is hurting them
instead of feeling grateful to God that
he has in Mercy spoken to them through
his humble instrument to show them their
dangers and their sins and they may put
them away before it shall be too late
for wrongs to be writed close quote Yeah
that's part of the 25 Page Letter She
Wrote
yes what was Ellen White claiming here
regarding canr I mean what what's she
claiming with regard to the Holy Spirit
first of all that she's the one that's
been appointed to convict sin and
reprove sin uh John 168 tells me that's
the holy spirit's job I will send the
Holy Spirit to convict of sin and to
reprove sin here again Ellen's engaging
in Gross
blasphemy while she calls herself humble
you know I I don't know how a person
could be more hypocritical than to call
yourself humble when you're engaging in
the most base form of blasphemy you
could possibly be engaging in and uh you
know this was just the way Ellen
operated anytime anyone stepped out of
line she was a control freak and
especially someone is threatening is
canr but even like the Elders of the
Battle Creek Church how does she
intimidate imate them and attempt to
control them the lord gave me a vision
showing you left the San the most
sanctifying meeting on the judgment and
went back to your rooms and engaged in
the base Vice
of masturbation you know and she's
telling all these people God showed her
a pornographic vision of them
masturbating in their
rooms and you know it's just this is a
public thing she's doing in the pattle
Creek Church woman it just has no
boundaries I mean you talk about the
most extreme
manipulation and exploitation you can
possibly do that's what she did and
that's how she operated if anyone
stepped out of line here came the
boatload of condemnations and and
they're all General I mean it's just so
stupid
that for anyone to take her seriously
when you know everything that is out
there that she wrote is you know you
just have to say this person needs their
brain examined or something I mean it's
just like what a statement like talk
about no fear of God can you can you
imagine ever saying such a thing we we
laugh but it's just because other the
only other option is to cry absolutely I
mean can you imagine yourself Steve
making such a
statement it's just crazy to think
I've never I've never had a thought to
think God showed me your secret sins you
were you know tugging one off in the the
room after the meeting or you know or
instead of being at the meeting and
there's just so many problems with this
yeah there's so many problems with this
and like you said for any person that
knows all of what's out there and has
heard all the defense oh you know their
favorite one that was for a specific
time you know dancing and dancing and
chess were were were associated with you
know lewd behavior um I know she said
not to take a bath on the Sabbath but
you don't realize they had to it was a a
lot of work you had to walk down to the
river and get water and it so that it
was only a you know a time based
prophecy for a specific period you know
it was Only Sinful you know in the 18
you know 1900s 1800s to uh take a bath
on Saturdays because it was a lot of
work but now that we have modern day
Plumbing eh it doesn't really apply
anymore even though her writings making
no distinction uh are a continuing and
prophetic source of authority it's just
so many problems so so I mean it was a
different time they didn't have John 168
then they
didn't 10
then blasphemy was then I mean come on
the woman is a blasphemer it doesn't get
much worse than that than grossly
misrepresenting God and making God out
to be a liar and a fool I mean come on
it's just so disgusting that uh and the
woman got away with it you know it's at
least Bernie madof got caught before he
died yeah but Ellen you know she's
gotten away with it for more than 100
years after she died and and they're
trying to cover it up for longer just
like they did with the
1919 Bible Conference minutes that was
the one chance where it looked like the
church might actually try to be honest
but no
they had to bury those minutes for more
than 50 years and when they did come out
Arthur white grabbed them and wouldn't
allow any church member to see it till
he was out of office and it was leaked
by Spectrum to the public I mean it's
just the way they operate the white
estate is grossly dishonest and Tim is
grossly dishonest and they won't own it
it's the bottom line well and that's
Steve that's why I constantly say on
this platform and I've been saying for
over a year now um at least publicly
like this that their favorite the the
Commandment keeping Church's favorite
commandment to break is bearing false
witness absolutely it's just it's the
recurring theme and it's like why are
you guys like this well because of money
power and control that's ultimately what
it comes down to yeah so the central
focus of your most recent book centers
around Carrie Johnson yes and her
book
correct and and their book I guess I
should say their book not her
I was can's secretary right who was
Carrie Johnson and what was her big
lie yeah that was it that she was canri
secretary that was as big a lie as she
could possibly tell although uh when you
look at her life and even the testimony
of her own grandkids She Was a Serial
pathological liar that's just what she
did and she was a a classic sociopath as
well uh real quick Steve yeah one thing
you said there just because I don't
wanted to get buried when you speak
about her grandkids who are you talking
about and why are you referencing them
because I think one of them uh has
something to do with your book yeah yeah
she's listed as a contributor Nancy page
is her name and it's actually because of
her that I decided to write the book
when I was doing my daily Facebook
thread she was on and I got to know her
and I was fascinated that she was Carrie
Johnson's granddaughter and was very
interested in the things she was saying
so I did an extensive interview with her
that I recorded and I said you know
there's material here that really needs
to be explored and examined and uh I I
think it's worthy of a book and um she
was yeah yeah great others have said
it's worthy of a book but nothing ever
happens but I was serious about it and
um you know she uh was a great
contributor and her brother and um it
was just something that um if it hadn't
been for them you know as I as I've
written many times if it wasn't for
Nancy page and it wasn't for Norman dowy
uh I could have never written that book
those two witnesses were so important
and so
powerful thatth the book could not have
been written without them so uh I owe a
great Deb of gratitude to both of them
of course D's no longer with us but
Nancy is and uh she was with me in the
interview uh with Peter Dixon on U SDA
Q&A but um generally speaking you know
she doesn't like to be out in public I
she doesn't consider herself a public
speaker particularly and um so I I'll do
most of the interviews myself but um
you know her her grandmother
was a thief she was kicked out of the
Adventist Church for stealing Church
funds and um she she was a typical
sociopath she could butter up people
that she wanted to impress and get close
to just like Ellen White could but it at
the root at the core there was evil
there and a mistreatment of her grandkid
she exploited them she abused them um
she was an opportunist always looking
for an opportunity to uh benefit herself
at the expense of others and she made
her grandkids do all the work for a
apartment she rented that she got paid
for and she never gave them a scent for
painting it and cleaning up all the
messes and crap and everything that was
involved with that uh Nancy goes goes
into detail in the interview but um you
know she was just a a sick person um she
really had a major pathology and major
dishonesty and um you know after all
possible Witnesses are
dead she comes up with this claim and
and I think the reason she came up with
it was because she was close to uh
Andrews and she knew Arthur white came
to Andrews and he was the head of the
whole white estate
nationally and uh she was a a clever
conniving kind of person and she'd heard
she was in Battle Creek a short time and
she'd heard of
canr um when she was young and now she
realized hey everybody's dead that can
possibly testify against this story so
she just completely creates the story
knowing that Arthur White's going to
probably want to jump at something like
this because canr right's such a hated
person and his influence was getting
greater not less with the other churches
this was a period when adventism were
being completely renounced as a cult so
uh in 1950 she introduces herself to
Arthur white and claim she was canri
secretary and he goes crazy oh wow yeah
we got to get your witness we got to get
your
testimony you got to write a book about
this and you know it's a fairly small
book it's something you could write in a
year especially if you're just speaking
out of your own personal testimony but
obviously she wasn't uh you know Arthur
white could see very quickly that she
didn't have the good she didn't have the
personal experiences she didn't even
know how long she worked for the guy she
claimed different times two years 18
months uh seven months is what it
finally came down to but those seven
months can be proven to be absolutely
false that canr wasn't even there you
know he had his own secretary that was
his next door neighbor uh there was
absolutely no way that she was his
secretary but then the book also proves
that there was no way that she ever even
met the man because she claimed to his
family and to Dy that she saw that he
had a peg leg when she knew him uh which
was completely false what she had tried
to do was do research on canr when she
came up with this lame brain idea and
she either mixed canite up with one of
his relatives who had a peg leg or she
believed a false rumor that canr had
lost his leg in a Hayfield accident when
he was a kid because that's what she
told the family you you know how stupid
can you be to tell a man's own family
that he had a peg leg when they know
that he
didn't and uh and all the neighbors all
the witnesses that dowy brings out in
the book all say you know she's
completely crazy uh he had two good legs
he worked hard on those legs the other
possibility which I doubt that this was
her confusion but before he died canr
had an accident shortly before he died
in
1919 and he had to have a leg amputated
but her her claim to can right's family
was that he had lost his leg in a hay
accident which was the false rumor that
had been spread and uh so she simply
bought that false rumor and and didn't
didn't admit where she got it from she
claimed it as fact that she had actually
seen this when she worked for can right
so you know the woman is so
discredited in a million different ways
it's like dowy said she lied when there
was no benefit in lying she just Blain
couldn't tell the truth so she couldn't
speak
without misrepresenting the truth no
matter what she was saying and so she
was just a pathological liar and um once
Arthur white realized this and realized
that canr didn't have a peg leg and that
she was completely
duded and that uh you know she didn't
know what she was talking about he
didn't want to let go of the idea hey we
got can right here we have a woman who's
willing to claim she was his secretary
so let's run with this and just create
dest sty ourselves so he meets with her
on a regular basis for 20 years and
basically tells her what to write and
her grandkids witnessed this and um
so you know it's really all about Arthur
white he's really the one who wrote the
book he's really the one who got it
published um this is much more about
Arthur white than Carrie Johnson because
she's an really just a criminal and an
evil person that had no standing
anywhere whereas Arthur white was the
head of the white estate that's quite a
big difference here you have the head of
the white State stealing a diary
colluding with Carrie Johnson to keep
they both denied ownership so they could
keep the diary in the white estate which
is it's there to this very day I mean
they're thieves they're Liars there
Arthur white should be discredited from
every award he was given he should had
the honorary doctorate taken away from
Andrews he should be cut off from the
white estate for all the years he he
should be uh discredited as the bio
biographer of his grandmother all six
volumes that the church considers the
official biography I mean this man is is
an
embarrassment and uh it's an
embarrassment to the white state that he
represented them all those years and
none of them are owning it you know
right they they wanted do the usual
let's just cover it up and pretend it's
not real yeah which it's like it's not
198 anymore folks y it's a it's a
different era so who all who all was
involved in I was kri secretary you
mentioned Carrie Johnson and Arthur
white was it just those two they were
the two that put the whole thing
together and no one even knew about
Arthur white being involved except for
Carrie Johnson and her grandkids so I'm
very thankful that I was able to get the
witness of her grandkids before they
pass on because they up in years so well
and you mentioned too the the diary
which you talk about this a lot more in
depth in the book but for those in the
audience who may not know about that
what exactly was going on with that
because that's kind of a a a a key Link
in the whole product actually coming
about they they needed that diary in
order to uh to to bring this whole thing
about can you speak to that a little bit
more yeah once Arthur realized that
Carrie never even met canr much less
work for him uh he didn't want to let go
of the story but he realizes that Carrie
has nothing to offer him except lies so
now he has to try to build a story on uh
filler that he generates and then he
says but there has to be some kind of
personal information here if you
actually work for the guy so you need to
get a hold of his diary and uh Arthur
was aware that he had a diary out there
uh in the family so he uh
puts Carrie up to going out and meeting
with the family members getting to know
them making them believe that she's
writing this great sympathetic biography
of can R and that she loves the guy and
she honored him at his grave and he has
a street named after him and he was this
great wonderful person and she just
wants the whole world to know about it
never tells them she's coming from the
Adventist never tells them what her true
motives are
um so she completely lies and deceives
them uh and gets uh the relatives to
allow her to borrow the diary it was
supposed to just be borrowing for a
short time so she could go through it
and and take material that would be
helpful to making canite look like a
great
man uh as soon as she gets her hands on
that diary which she'd been trying to do
for some time Nancy says she was the the
happiest person in the world she went
straight to Arthur white this was their
deal she handed it to him he locked it
in the white
estate dowy and the family demanded it
back as soon as they realized uh that
they'd been duped and
deceived and U and Arthur white refused
to give it to them he tried to Stonewall
them forever and then he said well this
isn't our property it's it's uh the
property of
Johnson you'll have to talk to her so
then they go to Carrie Johnson and she
says no no I gave it to the white estate
I don't own it anymore and that's the
arrangement that Arthur and Carrie
worked out will both deny ownership
therefore they can't get the diary back
and it's still in the possession of the
white estate today because of that lie
because of that theft and
um what they really planned on doing was
now we can make up anything and
attribute it to uh can right's diary
because we're the only ones that have
access to it the problem was that Norman
dowy was a very shrewd smart guy and he
insisted on at least being able to read
the diary um they wouldn't allow him to
take any notes they wouldn't allow him
to make any copies but just the fact
that he read it uh he made it clear in
his book in
1964 that there was absolutely nothing
in that diary that was harmful to can
write so that really threw a major brick
in their plans because they wanted to
make up all kinds of lies and when
Carrie Johnson went out on the camp
meeting circuit as the big Adventist
celebrity she made up all kinds of lies
and attributed them to the diary and
stuff but uh they weren't in print so it
was a lot harder to uh for people to
know about it but the Adventist
audiences were eating it up there's
still one of those interviews on the
internet to this day that I have uh
referenced in the book that you can go
and she's just disgusting I mean she's
saying canite was completely
demon-possessed he spoke in these
demonic voices when he was trying to
dictate to her and I mean you couldn't
be any more Asing than what she is but
you know the Adventists were just eating
it up because this is their Public Enemy
Number One ah he was demon possessed he
was The Exorcist oh wow no wonder he
criticized Ellen White he was straight
from the devil you know this kind of
stupidity when canr was actually a man
of integrity an honest man a sincere man
a lover of God a believer in the gospel
and Arthur white and Carrie Johnson were
the opposite which adventism in general
tends to be the
opposite now Steve you know what the
Adventist response other people will
hear that but you know what the
Adventist response is g to be and and
it's going to be well that was Carrie
and Arthur or the white estate not the
SDA organization that's just individuals
of course individuals are flawed Etc how
has the SDA Church gone about
propagating and promoting this lie
because has the SDA church do they have
any blood on their hands when it comes
to I was kri secretary absolutely that
was the greatest book ever for the
church they promoted it like mad the
review and heral completely prostituted
itself it didn't even vet the book it
just took Arthur White's word for it so
they would have been subject to such a
ridiculous liable suit um that you can't
even comprehend and it could have
brought down the whole SDA church
because the whole church was promoting
this book promoting her as a celebrity
at all their camp meetings telling her
lies they were recorded lies that could
have stood up in
court um you know they dodged a bullet
basically uh the church reviewing heral
white estate it all could have been
taken down by the stupidity that Arthur
white engaged in and U there the
Adventist Church is so good at covering
things up and they live in their own
little isolated uh subculture away from
the rest of the world and accountability
to the press and all these kinds of
things that um you know they just
lie they lie and they lie and they lie
and U they're going to try to lie their
way through this in whatever way they
can but the whole church was involved in
this and the the book is still being
being published today you know it's
unbelievable that they're still
promoting this and advertising this as
if it's truth even after my book's
already out I was just gonna say I still
see this promoted I still people see
people citing it Etc so with that in
mind I want to play a small clip of
something that you said a couple years
ago in your discussion with Tom Norris
okay Ellen White Ellen White apologist
on the SDA Q&A out to Peter Dixon if
he's watching in the audience uh he's
going to actually be on uh in about a
month and a half or so um so shout out
to himis or Peter Dixon is what's that
did you say Norris is gonna be on or
Peter Dixon's gonna no no sorry yeah
that's probably confusing Peter Dixon
I've actually extended the extension to
uhh Tom Norris he has rejected um but
that door is still open Tom if you want
to come on here if you happen to be
watching this um I I the you know what
we talked about and the do still open on
that stuff but let's listen to this and
then I'll have a question for you
afterward okay relying on canr at all
you said that on your website you
admitted it and and it's and I've quoted
it in my book so I so what you're saying
now is not even true what I you your
whole book is can
right that's a complete joke there's
nowhere in my book where I talked about
relying on canr nor did I rely on canri
you say you like canri you think he's a
great guy I I do think can right was
grossly U misjudged and condemned by
Ellen in ways that simply won't stand up
to what was fair and honest and Dow's
book is a great book I don't know if
you've read it uh I don't know if you
take Carrie Johnson's book I was can
write secretary seriously but if you do
I feel sorry for you and you're going to
feel sorry for yourself when the
evidence comes out on that I suggest you
read what Peter's going to post up and
and look at the sources Peter can post
it up fine I'm glad to look at what
you've put up but uh the the bottom line
is that I've put 326 heavily extensively
documented sources and you haven't
reputed anything you know so it's well
no one's asked me to no one's asked me
to I can easily refute everything you've
said
and I have and it's been written you
just haven't seen it yet okay well
that's an easy thing to
say
wow I've seen that I've seen that that
clip well a bunch since I clipped it out
for this but I've watched that
discussion probably five or six times
just as an analysis of of Ellen White
apologetics and the sort of of of of
claims that are just made that it's just
par for the course but Tom was accusing
you of being a canright parrot regarding
your book on the Ellen White
psychobiography again we've seen that
made by Mr Alberto Tim you uh uh you
also mentioned your 326 sources that
Alberto Tim dismissed as well as Carrie
Johnson's phony book what we saw from
Tom folks was the standard response that
we get from Adventist apologist that
everything you claim has been refuted
it's all easily refuted it just you
haven't even read the materials you
haven't even seen this that sort of
thing so my question for you
Steve what are some of the strongest
evidences that Carrie Johnson never even
knew canr you mentioned some of those
earlier but then also it's a
two-parter now that the evidence has
been published in your book what are
some of those evidences because Tom says
they've all been answered and this was
again a couple years ago before your
book was published but now that it's
published what are some of the strongest
evidences that Carrie Johnson never even
knew
canr number one is the peg leg I mean
that that's just a completely ridiculous
claim and really a very stupid claim she
didn't need to make that claim and if
she hadn't made that claim it would be a
lot harder to prove that she never even
met krite but um you know it's one thing
if you said well um this guy actually uh
had two good legs when he had a peg leg
because you know be person could had an
artificial leg and hit it well or
something but when you're claiming they
have a peg leg when they have two good
legs that that's completely ridiculous
and um everyone knew it was
ridiculous um Arthur white knew it was
ridiculous that's why it wasn't included
in the book because it was discredited
by the whole family by everyone who knew
can right uh I mean Carrie Johnson just
made a complete fool of herself by
making that claim number one so that's
the most important claim she made that
proves that she never even met the guy
much less work for him then uh there's
not a shred of evidence as Nancy points
out uh
nothing not one piece of evidence to
show that she ever knew can riter worked
for him um every every single thing she
claims about going to the secretarial
College it wasn't a college uh the guy's
dead that could have confirmed it um
Nancy says she saw the manuscript of K's
writing she was completely unskilled had
no secretarial skills at all um she just
lied constantly as dowy said she was a
pathological serial liar and a thief and
anyone who takes her seriously you know
Arthur white wasn't even taking her
seriously he just realized hey here's a
person willing to prostitute herself and
claim she was canite secretary we have
to take advantage of this and make the
best of it and see how much mileage we
can get out of it which is precisely
what he did and what the Adventist
Church did of course the church didn't
understand that it was a fabrication
Arthur white understood it was a
fabrication so Arthur and kry were the
only two who knew it was a
fabrication but um dowy pretty much knew
it was a
fabrication and um you know he he wasn't
a wealthy person and he wasn't in a
position uh he was threatened with
lawsuits when his book came out in
1964 he didn't have the money to defend
himself against the whole denomination
of lawyers so he took the book off the
market uh you know it's it's an unfair
fight when you have a whole denomination
of lawyers going up against a person
who's not at all wealthy and not in a
position to pay for lawyers so um you
know dowy really could have hurt them
bad if they hadn't used such
intimidation tactics and uh went after
him and went after can right's family
threatening lawsuits and all this stuff
which was just the way avenus behave you
know they they bully when they anytime
they can bully to control if that's the
only Resort they have they'll definitely
bully and um so you know the the easier
question to ask is what evidence is
there that she ever met canr or worked
for him and that would be zero there's
absolutely zero evidence evidence
whereas there's absolutely overwhelming
evidence the day she claimed uh cam
right met with her for the first time
was the day his wife died he was miles
away it was a snowstorm there was no
possible way he left at 4 in the morning
to meet with her when his wife had just
died I mean every single thing you go
through on this is a an obvious lie it's
not even questionable so uh you know
people confront her or how come there's
not even a secretarial pad or or
anything that you can produce well it
was all burned in a fire oh why did you
have that stuff when you claimed that
you had um given it all to the Adventist
leaders why would they give it back to
you when canr was such a threat to them
they would have at least made copies of
something I mean there's just no common
sense here it's uh every single thing
she claimed won't stand up to facts
history Common
Sense any kind of honesty or Integrity I
mean it's just uh it's just a complete
joke um that this woman was ever taken
seriously and now anyone who takes
Arthur white seriously is guilty of the
same thing because Arthur white is just
as implicated in this whole thing as
krie Johnson
was so were you ever able to look over
Tom's supposed uh responses that just
completely destroy everything that you
have to say another lie you know he he
kept saying he was going to get it to me
he was going to get it to Peter he never
did the the document didn't exist oh he
never even shared it no um and it
someone said that he put something up on
the internet but then took it back down
but but you know Tom is is not a serious
person um you might say well why did you
agree to debate to him with him he he's
a very boisterous obnoxious uh badosha
type of person and he he gets on the
internet and he makes all these claims
and oh dy's afraid to debate me I've
I've tried to get him to debate me and
he refuses he's afraid of me uh you know
so I finally said I'm going to shut this
guy up he's so disgusting so I go on you
can hardly get a word edgewise in when
you listen to the debate he's just this
obnoxious ridiculous person and now he's
going around claiming that he won the
debate you know every single person that
uh listened to it or saw it that I'm
aware of said he did nothing but
embarrass himself you know he he was
just a complete joke and that's really
what he is you know he he's not a
scholar he's not he has no credentials
he has no
credibility
um it's really funny I've had a lot of
great real estate people I've worked
with in my life so I don't have anything
against Real Estate people but I've
never had a real estate person tell me
they know more about Theology and
history and psychology than I do but
that's what this guy does you know he
seems to know more about everything than
anyone and um it's just he's not worth
taking seriously I I would encourage you
not even to have him on your show if he
agreed to do it because the guy's an
embarrassment to himself and an
embarrassment to apologists even
apologists recognize that he's a joke
yeah and the only reason I extended it
was because he was popping off in a in a
group that I'm in on Facebook all the
time calling me a liar saying I didn't
know what I was talking about and so I
said all right come on to answering
adventism and let's let an audience see
who's done their homework who actually
can back up there because I'm not the
kid cheating off of my neighbor and
their homework and then trying to turn
it in yeah I have told people from the
beginning I didn't start this hastily I
started answering adventism after a
decade removed from adventism sitting
under sound qualified pastors and Elders
studying SDA Systematic Theology Etc and
I stand by the homework of this platform
am I above air of course not of course I
could make errors somewhere but if you
think I'm an heir come onto the platform
and let's do it well and then he started
singing a different tune so I don't
think so I don't think he'll actually be
on but that was the only reason that
that was actually extended now you've
mentioned a number of times tonight as
well as in that previous clip the name
Norman dowy yeah who was Norman Dy and
how does his book fit into this whole
thing Norman dowy was a person who had
an interest in adventism even before he
wrote the case for DM canr but um he got
to know Arthur white when he was doing
research on
adventism and
um then uh Arthur white was making
statements about uh canri that were very
derogatory just echoing he said oh I
have testimony from his secretary that
can Wright recanted and uh you know
repented and uh that he said he was a
lost man over and over and over again
and only wished he could come back to
adventism but knew he was a lost man and
I mean all the crap that Carrie Johnson
claimed and doubt he knew better uh and
so you know he started pressing the
subject and um Arthur white got quite
uncomfortable realizing this guy's got a
lot more gravitas than I do and uh uh
he's actually a very um great researcher
you know very very skillful care careful
person who wrote a great book uh the
case for Dam canri it's the best book on
can right's life and um it was just
really well done
and uh he also documented even though
they were threatening him with a lawsuit
if he mentioned Arthur's name or or
Carrie's name he still referred to a
woman claiming to be can rri's secretary
and basically spilled the beans on her
in a way where she couldn't sue him or
something and um but they still you know
intimidated him so much that the book
got taken off the market so it wasn't on
the market for very long but then it's
had a Resurgence of
popularity uh you know here in the TW
21st century uh now the book is free
available online and I encourage anyone
who uh has an interest in adventism to
read it surprisingly a lot of Adventist
Scholars have never heard of dowy or
read his book I was interested when I
was talking to John Butler who's a
friend of mine recently and asked him
about what he thought of dy's book he
said he hadn't heard of it or read it so
you know he's a top L and white scholar
it just shows you how people get kind of
focused in their areas of research and
just because a person has a PHD doesn't
mean they know everything about that
subject it's it's simply not true you
know the more you focus in on a specific
question then you learn a lot about that
one question but you still you don't
know everything about it you know yeah
and that was going to be my next
question to you because again I I'm not
I don't think a good sample of this
because I was just kind of a leoty etc
um but for someone like you who worked
in you know Academia SDA Academia um did
you ever hear about Norman dowy I never
heard about him in any of my classes I
had numerous classes in Adventist
history and my Master's degree on that
um at the
Seminary at uh my undergraduate training
there was a great history Department
there dy's name was never mentioned
there is one footnote in in schwarz's
book light Bears to the remnant that
just mentions Daddy but he was never
mentioned in class um you know it's like
Adventists are completely ignorant of
who dowy is and
um I didn't I didn't really get into
reading Dy till I uh wrote the
psychobiography as I was doing research
for the
psychobiography then of course I was
going into the critics of adventism in
in great depth and dy's name became
important at that point but I found it
on my own I studied him on my own and uh
most Evan seemed grossly ignorant of who
he was and what he
wrote why do you think that amongst the
critics he's a name that's not or hardly
ever mentioned surely not like a Dale
ratl a Walter Ray um a Desmond Ford why
is dowy the name that's only ever
sprinkled in so for example in Jud
Lake's book he mentions dy's name and
the name of dy's book he doesn't touch
anything that dowy actually says in his
book yet he does at least try try to
appeal to things canri says as we're
going to see momentarily um why do you
think that is why do you think that they
uh they don't treat dowy the same way
that they do uh canri and the
others for for the definite reason that
dowy uh is not a direct threat to Ellen
White the way
um most of the critics that they're
worried about uh I I think one reason
they're so worried about me and they're
trying to silence me and censor me in
every way they possibly can is because I
was in Adventist Academia for 24 years
um I wrote the book adventism for New
Generation which was used as a textbook
in Adventist colleges and universities
for
years so um you know I I I'm a licensed
psychologist I I have uh major academic
Works in history as well as Theology and
so they're really threat en by that you
know if it's a rat Swift they'll say oh
he was a high school teacher or
something but it's it's a lot harder for
them to dismiss me um I have the goods
on them a lot more and um and I'm a
researcher who has strong academic
credentials and and understand research
more than probably any of them because
I'm trained in research at a level that
none of them are trained in so um you
know I I think dowy was not a threat to
Ellen White directly he was a threat to
uh their attempt to discredit canite but
they got his book off the market so no
Adventist even heard of him so you know
they they weren't worried about dowy
because he was not an Adventist and he
uh had really no exposure to Adventist
and Adventists were even taught if it's
not an Adventist don't read it you know
so uh it's almost impossible to find
Adventists who've even heard of Dy much
less read
him yeah that was definitely the
experience that I had but again I I
don't think I'm necessarily a good
sample on that but even post you know
leaving adventism where I've done the
most of my my digging and my reading of
you know the Adventist you know B
articles and their apologists and those
sorts of things um you hardly ever see
any sort of
um you know long-winded response or
dealing with dowy the same way that you
do other critics but with that in mind I
want to look at what Dr Jud Jed Lake
States regarding canri in his criticisms
and then I want to get your thoughts so
notice what he writes he says quote just
before canri left the Adventist Church
he heard Butler and Smith talking about
GI Butler appeal to Ellen White for an
authoritative word on the law in
Galatians 3 but he wasn't at the 188 8
General Conference session when she
turned the attention to the delegate or
or uh she turned the attention to the
delegates back to the Bible and away
from her writings as the final word on
any biblical subject furthermore she
spelled out the final authority of the
Bible in 1889 where she said the
testimonies are not to belittle the word
of God she explained but to exalt it and
attract Minds to it that the beautiful
Simplicity of truth may impress all canr
failed to notice these words
thus in his campaign against 7th day
adventism canr was fighting pre 1888
adventism not the adventism that has
moved on to Greater understanding of
God's plan for humankind his criticisms
were focused on what he remembered his
charges may have been true of pockets of
adventism but the denomination as a
whole had outgrown them close quote so
he claims that canri criticisms are
essentially invalid because they are
levied at an adventism that no longer
exists and has grown past the things
that canri claimed about them namely the
charges that he made about their Central
Focus being on the law and not Christ as
well as ad or Ellen White openly stating
that the Bible is the ultimate Authority
in adventism and not Ellen's own
writings that all supposedly changed at
the 1888 General Conference and canri
just wasn't tuned into these changes
that's why he was Ill informed so Steve
was 1888 really this big turning point
in adventism that completely neutralizes
any of the criticisms regarding
adventism being legalistic because they
love to still use this defense today for
example they'll they'll Levy this at the
stuff I say all the time that you're
attacking an old adventism that's just
not around anymore that's pre 1888 you
know righteousness by faith
adventism what say
you uh gross ignorance on the part of
most Adventist about 1888 uh including
lake lake uh teaches homiletics is that
what he teaches or does he also claim to
be a systematic Theologian what what are
his claims he's a professor of preaching
preaching yeah okay homiletics okay
that's what he acts like uh that's what
he writes like uh homti are not known
for being Scholars and he clearly
doesn't strike me as a
scholar by the ignorance that seems
quite pervasive when he talks about
1888 um he seems to have no
comprehension of uh you know he he'll
take her 1901 statement at the general
conference which I used to quote too you
know never quote my words again go with
the Bible the Bible
Alone um you know that's a typical
apologist thing for Ellen White if they
don't want to uh
try to defend the visions and the all
the garbage that's attached to her um
but the bottom line is that even those
statements from the 1901 General
Conference session where she addressed
the delegates
before
um she had even her own motivations
there you know she'd been in Australia
for 10 years she'd been colluding with
Daniels they had their big plan about
how they were going to come back and
take over the church and she was going
to get back all these people who send
her to Australia besides that Anar
Phillips was a propheus who was gaining
great momentum in adventism at that time
uh she came into major prominence after
the 1888 conference and she was embraced
by Wagner and Jones she was embraced by
Prescott she was embraced by hll a
number of the top leaders in the church
felt like she was a true prophet in
contrast to how Ellen White was
operating and I I would agree I think
Anar rice Phillips uh met the role of a
new testament Prophet that she was
actually a legitimate prophetic person
in the context of the New Covenant and
the new testament which Ellen White
wasn't by any stretch I don't care how
you try to argue and uh so Ellen comes
back and Anna is getting all this
attention and all these all this
following so now oh don't pay attention
to prophecy uh just go by the Bible in
the Bible alone Ellen White already had
her Authority and status you know she
already had all these books out and when
you talk about
1888 Adventists are so ignorant about
this it it really troubles me but um you
really have to go back to
1854 and uh study what was
happening at that time JH Wagner who was
uh you know EJ Wagner's father he wrote
a book called The Law of God and it's
the closest thing to True gospel ever
written by an official
Adventist this he understood that the
law in Romans and Galatians was not the
ceremonial law as Adventist claimed but
it was the full law it was the full old
Covenant law that you can't be under
grace you can't be under the perfect
finished work of Christ and under the
old Covenant law at the same time it's
an
impossibility it's a gross mixture
that's
um completely unhealthy theology which
is where Adventists have always been of
course early on they were just gross
perfectionists and legalists and you
have to understand that James White and
Bates came out of um you know the most
legalistic and and unorthodox I mean
this was a complete the Christian
connection movement that they came out
of was absolute heresy they didn't
believe in the Trinity they didn't
believe Jesus was God I mean they were
completely heretical and Ellen never
challenged her her husband or Bates on
these views uh while they were
alive you know she she was just
remarkably silent on their anti-
trinitarianism and denying Jes Jesus Is
God and she went right along with their
gross perfectionism and legalism JH
Wagner was trying to break all this in
1854 but everyone was against him Smith
was against him James was against him uh
all the other top leaders were against
him uh Ellen White saw that they were
against him so she claimed to have a
vision that his book was wrong and they
all jumped on that bandwagon and banned
his book book uh didn't allow it to be
published after that and
um Wagner's son uh JH JH Wagner's son EJ
Wagner uh worked for him at the signs of
the times and him and Jones were running
the signs of the times before 1888 they
were the big wigs they were the ones
writing the editorials and everything
and they started writing the very same
thing that JH Wagner had written back in
1854 and Smith and GI Butler went
insane because they said hey Ellen White
has already debunked this and already
shown that this is heresy and uh here
they are writing this in the signs of
the times a church paper so Smith is
writing all his editorials in the review
fighting against them and they're having
this open Warfare in the church
papers and Ellen gets really pissed and
she says we're looking like fools you
know our our papers are fighting against
each other and and so she told them all
to shut up basically and uh she said you
know Smith and Butler right they're
bringing up my vision and that was my
vision so they're right but I want all
of you to shut up basically and and quit
fighting with each other so as soon as
she says they're right to Butler and
Smith they go crazy and they publish
Ellen White has endorsed us we're right
she said we're right based on her
Visions from God and Wagner and Jones
are wrong and Ellen just gets totally
angry uh she just feels totally betrayed
that Butler Butler writes a whole book
on the subject and Smith is writing
editorials like mad so she's really fit
to be tied and she's so angry at Smith
and Butler that she uh says I think
Wagner and Jones need to be able to
speak at the
1888 General Conference because you guys
went back on the agreement that you
weren't going to continue this fight so
you know anyway then she sees how
popular Wagner and Jones are but she
never Embraces the message of Wagner and
Jones that's where most Adventists who
try to claim that Ellen White became
this great gospel
Advocate uh are wrong Ellen White Never
embraced what Wagner and Jones were
saying about the law uh and that was
their whole Topic at the 1888 conference
the law of God the law of God in Romans
and Galatians that was their topic
that's what they spoke on every day it
was all that were not you know the the
aist teaching that were under the it's
the ceremonial law that's being talked
about in Romans and Galatians that's
wrong it was the more moral law it was
the old Covenant law it was the whole
law it was the whole law of condemnation
that's what they were teaching and Ellen
would not Embrace that because it wiped
out the fourth Commandment it wiped out
their claim to be the remnant and all
this kind of stuff so she just latched
on to certain aspects of righteousness
by faith and justification by faith that
were very popular with the people and
she ran with that getting visions of
writing new books slank steps to Christ
and oh boy look at all the money that
can come in with Desire of Ages and you
know which is precisely what she did
with this stuff she had a whole new
series of books that came out on the
Life of Christ Etc all based on Wagner
and Jones and the popularity they had in
the church but you know she lost
incredible uh amount of credibility also
because Wagner and I mean because Butler
and Smith were saying holy Toledo she
completely contradicted her own Visions
she completely contradicted what she
just said before and that that Wagner
and Jones were wrong now she's saying
they're right now she's saying they're
the third Angel's message and Verity I
mean it's just typical Ellen White
flip-flopping for popular uh appeal and
because the masses were turned on to
Wagner and Jones so she wipes out Butler
and Smith Smith even has to step down
his review and Herold and go under at
Jones and Butler gets kicked out of the
presidency and um you know but Ellen
loses a lot in that a lot of church
leaders are saying holy Toledo this
woman is dangerous she's a control freak
she'll she's willing to contradict her
own Visions for political reasons and so
let's get her the heck out of here
because the plagarism stuff was all
coming out right at that same time in
the secular press in
1889 so they ship her off to Australia
and she never forgets it she's uh quite
resentful of that and makes it very
clear that she didn't want to go so she
comes back with a vendetta to get rid of
the uh GC presidents and the people in
office and power and she puts Daniels in
and then they become uh you know
colluding buddies up until her death and
then Daniels knows that you know I I
didn't bring up the fact that um I think
that was one of your other questions
that um Willie white knew good and well
that Ellen's Visions weren't what the
church claimed them to be Daniels knew
that too almost everyone who knew Ellen
White well knew that her Visions were
nothing like what the church was
claiming they were claiming God spoke to
her gives her all this detailed
information Willie when he trains uh
Fanny Bolton says no the Visions are
nothing like that there's no words
there's no details she gets kind of
these panoramic
pictures and
um you know that's all there is to it
that's all the Visions are and uh then
of course he didn't say that she filled
them in with all the plagiarisms and all
the stuff she was getting from other
authors but I don't believe if she got
anything from God personally you know
Willie at least was claiming that he
believed that she got these kind of
panoramic views but U you know who knows
what she dreamed she was such a uh this
was a woman who had an extreme desire to
be somebody and um very unusual the
amount of drive and uh willfulness she
had and control and desire for power and
um I'm sure her dreams were informed by
that and of course she just made stuff
up all the time too like she did with
the 25 Page Letter against can writes
but um anyway I don't want to ramble too
much but no there there's a lot of good
there um I just find it interesting
because as I'm reading Dr L's book um
again it's kind of the same thing I was
thinking regarding Alberto Tim's paper
it's are you do you just lack complete
self-awareness yeah the same thing
you're criticizing others of doing which
in Dr Lake's case in his book and even
as a student I talked with him about
this numerous times specifically
regarding health message stuff the
constant criticism was well no no no no
you're taking that out of context he's a
huge well what's the context the one he
loves to appeal to is to say when people
say that Ellen White said you know you
shouldn't say I'm saved you have to
understand the context that was just
refuting the heresy of once saved always
saved she wasn't saying that you know
the other one they love to use no no
Ellen White claimed she would she didn't
she never claimed to be a prophet she
said I I don't claim to be a prophet yet
you go and read the quote and in the
very next paragraph she says because the
reason why and it's because the work
she's doing is far more than a prophet
the
name yeah I consider myself to be the
Lord's messenger with with direct
messages you know for the people of God
so she's saying the exact opposite of
what they cite the quote for they quote
it to say well no she was downplaying
herself when no she was totally
upswinging herself yes I'm more than a
prophet I am the holy spirit because I
convict sin and reprove of sin I'm also
the testimony of Jesus because I am the
spirit of Prophecy I mean and if you go
and if you go against the shut door
you're insulting the spirit of God right
absolutely it was blasphemy against the
Holy Spirit at that time it was present
truth that you had to go along with this
absolutely so I want to transition here
into um the figures involved in the
cover up at the white estate namely
Arthur and Willie white you just
mentioned Willie white here recently um
on page 10 of the book you write
this for the first 63 years of its
existence the white estate's day-to-day
operations were controlled by Ellen
White's son Willie and her grandson
Arthur both men were painfully aware
that their positions were uh were the
product of nepotism and did their best
to put forward a front of of objectivity
but it was only a facade in Willie's
case he was fully aware that the nature
of his mother's so-called Visions was
nothing like what the prophetess had
claimed and the church had been taught
close quote so you just mentioned this
in passing yeah can you expand on this a
little bit more for the audience are you
saying that there is evidence that shows
Arthur and Willie white were involved in
upholding um that Ellen was someone that
she was
not absolutely I mean uh Willie white in
his training of
U you know uh and of course Doris
Robinson was with him Doris was uh a
male d o r s and he was the uh
grandson-in-law of Ellen White so he was
in the nepotism world too but U when
they trained Fanny Bolton who was kind
of naive about things you know she had
been converted to adventism and she was
all an Ellen White worshipper she was
way more uh serious about Ellen white
stuff than Ellen was as far as all her
um all her stuff but um you know she was
a strict vegetarian oacl vegetarian
Etc and um Ellen was down in the pork
200 lb porkers but U anyway um when when
they get her back to California and
start training her they don't want her
thinking what the church members in
general think about the Visions they
have to help her realize hey that's not
what you're G to run into here um you
know she gets these quotes panoramic
General views uh it's the way he
describes it is it's almost aoke like
something she might dream at night or
something um nothing to do with God uh
downloading all this information that
they claim in the 2000 visions and stuff
where she's writing out page after page
that God supposedly dictates to her I
mean Will's very candid about that no
it's nothing like that uh and yet that's
exactly what the church was taught and
what they
believed so uh
right off the bat you know Fanny was
exposed to the fact that holy Toledo
this isn't what I thought it was going
to be and uh and then all the plagarism
and everything starts coming in after
that and it's not surprising that both
Maran and Fanny uh were at their wit's
end trying to work for Ellen given what
she was pulling off but um the more they
knew the worse it got for them and of
course Ellen then turns on them
does everything she can to basically
destroy especially Fanny because Fanny
was willing to talk about things and you
just couldn't do that if you were part
of Ellen's Inner Circle but you know my
own my own bias is that uh Willie
certainly knew and Arthur no doubt knew
because he was living in the home with
Willie he was a son he heard all the
discussions he knew what was going on he
inherited the wi state from his father
so whatever Willie knew and believed
Arthur would have known um so and all we
have to do is look at Arthur in this
last book to see that he's the most
mavian kind of personality
imaginable just a scumbag yeah absolute
scumbag you know it just that's just the
succinct way to put it yeah for those in
the audience that may not know you've
mentioned this a couple times and it's
kind of a perfect segue from from
coverups question for
you what was the 1919 Bible Conference
and why was it such a big
deal yeah it was such a big deal because
it was really the first time in
Adventist history where the church was
trying to Grapple with the truth and
Daniels and Prescott and all these
people knew the truth that Ellen wasn't
who she'd claimed to be uh she wasn't
who the church had been told she was
they they they felt like now she's dead
so we can deal with this stuff in a way
that can maybe Salvage uh some kind of
healthy
perspective and not just keep uh
reinforcing the same lies and
mythologies and um you know pathology
and um most of the people at the 199
Bible Conference were on the same
wavelength but you had Washburn and a
few others there who swore to secrecy
they would be they would respect the
confidentiality but it was a total lie
again they had no intention of
respecting the confidentiality of the
conference and they were seething with
anger because they were a small minority
of people and they realized totally
Toledo uh all the major leadership
including the GC president and everyone
knows Ellen was a plist they they know
she was basically claiming to be
something she wasn't and that the church
was believing she was something she
wasn't and uh boy we got to get rid of
all these people so they go out and
immediately violate the confidentiality
they'd sworn to and start sending out
all these papers to church members
saying that Daniels needs to be fired
and all these people they just basically
conducted a purge and sure enough
Daniels was out at the next GC all his
Prescott all these people that had been
close to him were out they put in the
most reactionary the next 30 years of
adventism was what I call the real dark
ages of adventism even worse than when
Ellen White was alive because you had
the apologist just taking over the lies
just taking over the 1919 uh transcript
should have gone in the whitest State
they are the ones that
oversee that kind of information but
instead they buried them in the GC
archives knowing that U no one would
know where they were no one would know
where to find them and sure enough
people gradually die off and no one
knows anything about them they disappear
they they become uh as if they never
were and it's not until uh you know 1974
when someone asked Donald yast about
what what what was the conference that
took place in 1919 and he starts going
through the whole GC archives and finds
these transcripts that were purposely
hidden and purposely
forgotten um by you know these
reactionaries who took over the church
chur and wanted no part of any kind of
honesty and during that 30-year period
you had the most
andreason FD nickel you talk about Ellen
White apologists I mean these are people
that buy into to her perfectionism by
into Jesus the model man Theory they
take the very worst of Ellen White and
they you know when when Lake tries to
claim adventism became this great thing
after
1888 he's either grossly ignorant or
grossly dishonest I don't know which it
is but anybody who knows Adventist
history knows that this 30-year period
between 1920 and 1950 was about as
terrible as it can get in terms of uh
Adventist apologetics and lies and
honoring Ellen White and elevating Ellen
White in ways that were completely
untenable um they believed a lie that's
all there is to it and that was really
for them the wonderful age of adventism
that it was growing based on all their
perfectionistic lies all their Remnant
lies all their egw
lies so I mean the
1919 Bible Conference was the last gasp
where the church had a hope for becoming
honest and it got squelched and smashed
and stepped on by the
apologists and it's never really
recovered from that you know once once
those transcripts were discovered then
you had numbers then you had um you know
the whole Glacier View thing with Ford
then you had Ray and then you had the
internet kind of exploding then you've
got my books and all this stuff uh is
all post
1974 when those transcripts were
uncovered but
um you know it's I don't know what L
smoking when he tries to act like post
1888 is this wonderful adventism
anything the opposite is true especially
1919 Bible Conference and not just that
but he's talking about how FD nickel you
know has silenced all you know all these
critics and all this stuff man FD nickel
is like well past
1888 oh yeah and he's still and he's
still dealing with criticisms that
you're claiming are pre 1888 criticisms
which is why can right's criticisms are
supposedly invalid but regarding Ellen
White's plagiarism um I want to look at
a common defense given by sdas by way of
hearing it from their Scholars and
academics so again referring to uh Dr
Jud Lake in his book this is what he
writes
quote for those like can right who
espouse a more rigid view of inspiration
alen White's literary borrowing poses a
special problem if God gave her the
exact words they argue why would she
need to use the words of uninspired
writers to express the divine revelation
inspired writers get all their
information directly from God so they
don't need to borrow expressions from
the writings of other human beings this
understanding of inspiration doesn't
take into account the literary borrowing
done by the writers of the the
Bible as noted below the Bible is
replete with literary borrowing as well
as other many other as well as many
other modes of divine human
communication alen White's use of
literary borrowing to express the
content of her Visions was no different
from the practice of the biblical
writers they often used a literary
borrowing to express the Divine truths
given to them through Revelation and
this biblical practice is best explained
with the whole person model of
inspiration that takes into account both
Divine guidance and human participation
close quote so you've obviously heard
this defense before Steve it is a common
one that they give to defend Ellen White
they claim that since the biblical
writers engaged in plagiarism themselves
it shouldn't be used against Ellen White
what are your thoughts on that
defense uh it's just really sad it's
hard to believe that a person claiming
to be a scholar would uh even write
those words but uh you know anyone who
understands anything about biblical
literature and especially the times in
which the Bible you know was
written
um people don't understand that I would
expect any scholar to know this but you
know the average person doesn't
understand that the Bible of those
ancient times did not have chapters and
it didn't have
verses um there was no way of referring
to Romans
6:14 none of that
existed um it was a completely different
period most people didn't even have
access to the scripts to the um
manuscripts and the scholars the
Pharisees the the rabbis
they had the scriptures memorized word
for
word uh Jesus knew the scriptures word
for word Paul knew the scriptures word
for word it was completely understood
even the people had a verbal uh
knowledge of scripture that goes Way
Beyond anything we can comprehend today
because oral traditions and people
didn't have Printing and writing the way
they do you know in the post-reformation
period And so people memorize the Bible
even the common believer often memorized
most of scripture but not near to the
degree that the rabbis and the Pharisees
and these people did to to accuse Jesus
of plagurism when he quotes from the Old
Testament if he doesn't give a reference
or something it's just absolute
nonsense a person who would make this
kind of equation to Ellen White is
either smoking dope or being
deliberately deceitful um because all
the Bible writers who quoted from other
Bible writers knew exactly what was
going on there was no mystery here there
was no deceit here there was no attempt
to hide where they were getting this
stuff it was just completely known and
uh and there you're still talking about
inspired writers from inspired writers
but that that doesn't account for Ellen
White borrowing from a bunch of people
who write things that are completely
imbecilic uh vital force physiology and
all the crazy stuff Ellen White writes
that she gets from other writers that no
Adventist would try to say came from God
today I mean it's just so ridiculous
that
I I get really annoyed when someone of
Lake
stature makes this kind of an argument
it just causes me to lose what little
respect I may have had for him you know
and these other authors that they love
to appeal to they didn't take these
things from other people copyright it
and then make a bunch of money off of it
right precise and get and then get
really mad when they're deported to
Australia like you said earlier and
royalty is cut while they're gone and
they get fuming mad when their royalty
amount gets cut she demands the highest
royalties while other people aren't even
taking
royalties yeah right she's saying it's
not me it's not me it's God oh but I
sure want these
royalties yeah yeah everything about her
is problem and I know I got this stuff
from other people but no one's going to
do the same to me because I'm
copyrighting it that's right yeah okay
precisely
so we we've mentioned him a couple times
you talk about him a little bit in your
book Francis nickel FD nickel and his
influence within adventism many
Adventists I don't think you're even
aware of his influence on them as
modern-day sdas but you write this you
say quote much of what nickel wrote was
intended to offset and refute the very
damning criticisms that de uh uh that DM
canite had Le uh leveled against Ellen
which were gaining a great deal of
traction with the churches condemned by
adventism in the five decades after
Ellen's death as we shall see in the
next chapter so in the eyes of sdas
nickel was the primary dragon slayer of
these churches and the champion defender
of Ellen White during this period so my
question to you is what role has Francis
nichel played in covering up Ellen's big
lie a big role you know he he became the
champion spokesperson for Ellen as I
said he mentored Arthur uh he was much
brighter and much more educated than
Arthur Willie or any of these other
apologists uh he was the Super apologist
plus he was a very bright guy uh he he
got this Fame from being in these
debates with Shipley and San Francisco
that were covered in National newspapers
so he became the young Superstar of
adventism and then he put his mind to
apologetics and it was all about
defending Ellen White and this is that
30-year period of Darkness where Ellen
White becomes God and um it's largely
because of nickel you know nicholl's
just promoting her at every turn and
claiming that he can debunk any critic
who's ever thought of anything that
could possibly uh be termed negative
about Ellen White and um so nickel was a
huge Factor you know even when I was
growing up FD nickel was super famous uh
his books were
super promoted and well used in the
Adventist Church I heard about nickel
very young and um you know I I I didn't
come to realize that the guy was a fraud
for many years um and um but it doesn't
really matter if it's racism or shut
door or whatever it is you'll find him
using the same uh apologetic lies and
coverups for Ellen that uh and he became
the standard Bearer for that most of
like the apologists on my thread who say
dumb things get him from nickel uh
they're just parting nickel much of the
time because nickel obviously studied
this stuff way more than they do have
done but
he's like the poster child for uh any
sort of Adventist apologetics we did a
stream we did a stream a few months ago
dealing with Ellen White's racism yeah
and we dealt with actual historical
sources you know quotes from snook you
know BF snook and people that were in
high places of leadership back then
showing they all universally understood
the amalgamation statements and it
wasn't the repositioning that nickel
tried to say well you know it's it's
talking about uh uh uh uh being
unequally yolked right um you know these
sorts of twisting defenses no they all
understood what she said that everyone
believed the same thing until Nicholls
sort of you know he was sent on the hunt
to do a specific thing to find a ghost
so he found a ghost right um that that
type thing and when he was sent out on a
mission to do this specific thing that
the SDA apologist is then bringing to us
will no duh he was sent out to do that
specific thing and the defense that he's
giving is not a valid defense
but these are the people that they're
going to point to to say well this
person's already dealt with all of it
and if you don't actually mention them
in your book like you didn't talk about
him apparently enough in your book Steve
it's because you're too scared of the
sort of things that he's put forth when
in reality like you pointed out no it's
just irrelevant to what's being said
because it doesn't actually deal with
any of the valid criticisms precisely so
I want to look at another quote here
from Jud Lake only because it gives us
another uh sort of you know example to
use to launch into the next next
question this is from his analysis of
the testimony of Dirk Anderson I don't
know if you know who that is he runs non
sda.org notice what he says Anderson
wrote the forward to this last book yeah
that's right sorry um notice what he
says regarding Francis nickel and can
write though in this analysis of Dirk uh
Anderson's testimony he says quote I can
only wonder what he talking about Dirk
did when he came across FD Nichols Ellen
White and her critics did he read
through this book carefully or did he
put it aside thinking it couldn't refute
canr I don't know but it is interesting
that on his website and in his books he
rarely mentions Nicholls massive
apologetic and never seriously engages
its contents in fact most contemporary
critics of Ellen White rarely engage
with Nicholls answers to can right's
charges why because Nicholls work
although dated in some places provides a
thorough reputation of canr close quote
so we get a glimpse into the sort of
attitude that SDA and SDA Academia have
for Francis nickel I hear them parrot
him constantly like I said and their
Scholars will write stuff like this but
Steve we would be included in the
Contemporary critics of Ellen White camp
and he claims that modern critics don't
engage with FD Nichols defenses of Ellen
White where we get uh a pretty good
example of what you refer to as him
being seen as the Untouchable dragon
slayer what are your thoughts after
hearing a statement like that all just
again feel sorry for Lake that he's that
naive but um you know he may not even be
aware that Nicholls arguments are
completely outdated and and dishonest
much more than being outdated they're
dishonest he he completely misrepresents
the evidence of the shut door he
completely
misrepresents the evidence of
amalgamation of man and Beast it it's
completely obvious to anyone who knows
anything about Adventist history we know
exactly what happened um Ellen made the
statements referring to the black race
and there was a complete uproar in the
church this was Civil War times um
people were just going insane that she
could say something like that and then
there were others that were uh racists
that were all turned on that she had
said this Uriah Smith saw that this was
a huge problem so he took it upon
himself to be the ultimate apologist and
write this whole pamphlet trying to bail
Ellen out and the way he tried to bail
her out was to say that the amalgamation
of man and Beast was yes indeed
precisely what she meant human beings
and animals
reproducing but it wasn't the quotes
black race in America that the Civil War
was about to be fought over no this was
uh various Tri tribes in Africa and New
Guinea and I mean it's just complete
stupidity that oh oh that would just be
isolated to these various tribes that
also happen to be black people but um
you know the bottom line is that Ellen
and James well don't forget Steve it
wasn't only only those overseas it was
even the tribes here the Digger Indians
in America yeah
precisely which I wanted to mention but
uh but the bottom line is that
um you know Uriah wrote this Ellen and
James endorsed it they took it to camp
meetings and they sold it like mad uh
that this was the explanation for what
Ellen had written so it makes nickel out
to be a complete nitwit fool that he's
claiming that she meant something
entirely different when she specifically
endorsed what Smith said and said that
was the explanation to get her out of
the hot water that she was about ready
to melt
in you know the defense on that is just
so lousy
Steve it to me is just when I get on
that topic again folks you can go watch
that stream we went deep on this that
top it just I I I just have such a a
short patience on that because that's
exactly it and I did a video on this
talking about this about they put their
stamp of approval on Uriah Smith's paper
where they went out and sold this thing
at camp meetings where he's talking
about the the example of what she means
by amalgamation is people like the hot
and tot tribes the uh uh the Digger
Indians of the north Americas Etc and
says could anyone even disag he says in
there could anyone disagree when looking
at them and think that's how God
intended people to be he says that
doesn't he yes he says no thinking
person could look at these people and
and think no God didn't intend it to be
that way that they're they're like a
lower subspecies of of of human that's
kind of like hard to to label that's
what was being said and the defense to
it is well no no no Ellen White Never
verbatim directly said that she
supported that oh you're she just went
and sold it to around at camp meetings
and James White does have a statement
publicly on it where he says I review I
reviewed it and I prove what is in this
pamphlet so he does Ellen clearly even
so even if she didn't know Steve the
fact that you're going around selling a
book that you don't know that something
like that is in there I I just I have no
patience for that it's absolutely
despicable that you would defend
something like that it's nasty it's not
that didn't come from God the other
defense that oh she was just talking
about again this like relegated it was a
sin for a specific period of time even
if you're saying it's mixed marriages so
it was a it was sinful for a specific
period of time and SD will saywell what
advice would you have given during that
time uh hold up a second hold up a
second so God's what is a sin and what
isn't a sin is dictated by the current
like American
climate uh the the people that abolished
slavery that led the charge were
Christians you're saying those people
well it would have stirred things up at
the time so did
abolitionists this idea that oh sinful
during that time to have a mixed
marriage why well they'd be relegated to
a life of
misery says who well at that time you
have to again it's relegating something
to be a sin for a specific period of
time it just creates more problems that
doesn't solve the issue it just creates
more problems what it really shows is
that nickel was just a very dishonest
person he was smart he he knew exactly
what had happened he knew the history
but he deliberately lied and covered it
up and made it something that he knew it
wasn't to try to bail Ellen out and I
have just no respect for that exactly
another example of this is what Jed Lake
claims regarding Dale ratl so again
using the same tactic they always use DM
canright Durk Anderson you now Dale ratl
at the beginning of his critique he
recognizes that Dale was a fourth
generation SDA who received all of his
formal education from Adventist
institutions he graduated from the 7th
Day Adventist Theological Seminary
pastored two SDA churches and was a
Bible teacher in their school for many
years he recognizes all of that but
despite all of this the charge is made
that Dale is ignorant of what SD believe
and teach notice what he
writes quote there's an interesting
parallel between rats laugh and canright
ah this sounds familiar doesn't it Steve
didn't we just read a quote earlier
where we saw saw oh this we should do a
parallel between Steve Daly and canright
here we go again as demonstrated in the
previous chapter canri like many of his
fellow ministers never really grasped
the fact that Ellen White taught
salvation by faith alone in Christ and
resisted an overemphasis on the law he
was a product of the pre-1 1888
legalistic adventism and when confronted
with the facts regarding the true nature
of the law in relationship to the gospel
he found it incompatible with his
understanding of adventism rather than
embrace the concept of Law and gospel
working together resigned from the
Adventist Ministry and left the church
consequently he missed the intensity and
Clarity of expression with which Ellen
wrote on the relationship of
justification by faith and the law
during the years following
1888 in a similar way Dale Ratz life
never seemed to fully understand Ellen
White's teaching on salvation
since leaving the SDA Church in the
early 1980s Mr Ratz life has never
interacted with the studies related to
the Centennial of 1888 which set forth
the profound impact this message had on
the church and Ellen White the theme of
Salvation through Christ merits is
clearly evident in Ellen White's
writings it balances her statements that
discourage people saying I am saved this
statement by the way must be interpreted
in light of its immediate context
something that Mr Ratz life never
understood as an Adventist and continues
to ignore in his treatment of Ellen
White close quote so we see the
recurring Defence from them of saying
that critics are all ill-informed they
don't actually understand adventism they
haven't engaged any of the copious
amounts of works that they've put out
dealing with the criticisms Etc they've
said it about you Steve canri and
basically anyone else that leaves and is
critical question do you find it odd and
I I'm really curious about this because
of your background in psychology as well
do you find it odd that they make these
charges about individuals who were
taught adventism from Adventist
professors and theologians that then
went on to teach and preach in their own
institutions what does that say about
their
teachers these people know nothing about
adventism yet we paid them and they held
positions of teaching adventism within
our institutions for decades
yeah I'm sure the party line would be oh
ratzliff he became a forite and uh you
know he got contaminated right after
Glacier View like so many of those young
ministers that left the church and uh I
mean the superficiality of these
people's thinking is almost Unworthy of
addressing it so poor but I I always
have to ask myself the question how much
of it is gross ignorance on their part
part and how much of it is deliberate
dishonesty and I never know for sure um
you know which side of the scale is
tipping there but um what I do know for
sure is that Adventists have never
understood the perfect finished work of
Jesus Christ uh the
closest uh I ever saw in two individuals
one historically was JH Wagner uh which
his son EJ Wagner and and Jones were
very close to him but uh Ellen White did
not Embrace what they taught no evanst
in general did not Embrace what they
taught at the very best Adventists have
always been a mixture of Law and Grace
which scripture doesn't allow for there
can be no mixture of being under law and
under grace at the same time you read
either under law or you're under grace
um the old Covenant law is the law of
sin and death Romans 81 and2 um we're
under the law of the spirit as God's
people under the New Covenant which all
the principles that you can find in the
uh you know the Everlasting Covenant has
always contained God's principles and
David's a good example of how even in
Old Testament times a person could trans
send the old Covenant and live under the
Everlasting Covenant that's why David
puts the ark out for everyone
to uh worship before that's why he has
247 musicians playing around the ark
anyone who knows the old Covenant law
knows that that was the death penalty no
one could go into the ark it was only to
be in the most holy Place only the high
priest could go in once a year with a
rope t right around his leg if he was
unqualified he got yanked out dead um
David puts everyone including the
Gentiles in the camp before the ark it's
the most flagrant uh complete violation
of the old Covenant law that you could
possibly do and he does the same thing
with his soldiers feeding them the
showbread that belonged to the priests
alone that was the death penalty for
doing that under the old Covenant law
David was man after God's Own Heart he
was a man functioning under the
Everlasting Covenant which is the same
as the law of the spirit it's the same
as the New Covenant which is new only
because Christ revealed the Everlasting
Covenant as it had never been revealed
before that's why it's called new uh not
not because it wasn't around before the
Everlasting Covenant was always around
but adventism
must you know um they must honor the old
Covenant law because that's where their
fourth Commandment is and you know 2
Corinthians 3:7 and9 makes it clear that
that's a Ministry of death and
condemnation uh Adventists don't know
their Bible they've never known their
Bible uh JH Wagner had it right the only
other person that founded on his own was
brinsmaid when I was at the
Seminary uh 1978 I loved reading verdict
and present truth brm's two magazines he
understood that we're not under the old
Covenant law he taught that's where I
came to understand it for the first time
the true gospel the true perfect
finished work of Christ how all these
things fit together in scripture
Adventists have never understood them
they've never come close to
understanding them at the very best
they've had a mixture which is
double-minded
and the com combining of the hot water
of God's grace with the cold water of
human Works which God spits and vomits
out of his mouth so you know I my guess
is that Lake doesn't have a clue what
the true gospel is and uh he certainly
doesn't have a clue about advent's
history as I listen to
him yeah and he totally misrepresents
canite you know you're talking about the
avenus view on the law and there's going
to be a lot more um content in the
coming weeks actually at the turn of the
year we're going to be diving into this
a lot more because that's exactly it
Steve um adventism just does not have a
grasp on covenant theology at all it's a
totally it's just a total botch it's the
idea is that the New Covenant is
basically a doover of the old Covenant
um but not but not really because Jesus
basically gives you an extended
probation and then you just you keep
trying but like you're not fully there
yet and so then you're confessing your
sins to be transferred to the sanctuary
and then you have a clean slate again
but you're growing in Grace and you're
eventually trying to get to a point
where you're sinlessly perfect now so
you can stand before God without an
intercessor that's not what the old
Covenant was like either you break it
once you're disqualified Absol I hate to
break it to you Adventist you're
disqualified you're disqualified that's
what and that's what Steve is trying to
get at not that people just because they
hear you say that Steve and they're
going to think you're saying then we can
just commit adultery you're and it's
like man you are just you're you're not
getting it you're not getting it because
that you're not that's not what you're
advocating for what you're trying to
explain is that what was a Ministry of
death and the whole point of that like
you were saying was to ultimately Point
people to Christ that wasn't some unique
thing to 2,000 years ago as though David
and Abraham and I mean when Paul wants
to point to the gospel who does he point
to he points to Abraham he uses Abraham
as an example in Romans 4 to talk about
the exact same gospel that you and I are
affirming well I'm not sure Jed lake is
actually read canr on uh the same level
of with the same level of focus and
diligence that he thinks needs to be
done with people like FD nickel when it
comes to people like you and I because
notice what canright says in seventh day
adventism announced regarding his view
of the law right because again the the
claim is essentially like well just like
rats laugh you know they just instead of
recognizing how the law and the gospel
actually really function together they
just completely threw the law out and
they just left and abandoned adventism
all together notice folks this is what
DM kri himself says he says quote this
is from Seventh Day adventism renounced
page 305 and6 he says quote
antinomianism from anti meaning against
and Nas law against law is a term
applied to those who maintain that
Christians are under no obligation to
keep the law of God or to do any good
works if they commit any kind of sin it
will not hinder their salvation at all
if they only believe in Jesus salvation
is Holy of faith without any regard to a
man's Deeds see any
encyclopedia this is an abominable
Doctrine subversive to the gospel yet
seventh day Adventists brand all as
antinomians who do not agree with them
as to what the law of God is right I am
as much opposed to antinomianism as they
do I believe in strict obedience to law
in keeping the Commandments of God and
in the necessity of good works as
strongly as they do Luther vly opposed
antinomianism and yet taught the
abolition of the Mosaic law it is unfair
and unjust for Adventists to call people
antinomians who abhor that doctrine that
Doctrine being antinomianism close quote
absolutely does that sound at all like
what Jud Lake claimed no it doesn't
because can right's issue wasn't with
the law of God his issue was with
adventism unlawful use of the law of God
and how the law was to be defined so I'm
not sure Dr lake has actually read canr
as thoroughly as he expects the critics
of adventism to read Adventist Scholars
but we also see from lak statement how
again anytime someone points out their
legalism as it pertains to the law they
claim that it's an old criticism that
was dealt with in 1888 and it's no
longer valid regarding modern-day 7th
day adventism canri was spoton when he
claimed that anyone who disagree with
them gets accused of being an antinomian
that hasn't changed one bit I hear it
constantly I deal with hundreds of sdas
or engage with hundreds of sdas every
week Steve this comes up at
least 10 times a week at least this
charge has always brought up so if you
disagree it's the false dilemma fallacy
there's only two options like a false
dichotomy it's either you agree with us
or you're this thing over here right
it's like well no there's like there
could be a third fourth fifth sixth
seventh option but no it's always this
false dilemma now I don't want to spill
this would be my final question here I
don't want to spill all the beans on the
entirety of your book so this will be
the last question in the final chapter
of the book you talk about why this book
is important and you give 10
reasons one of which is that the SDA
church has been dishonest regarding alen
white I want to look at one more
statement as an example of such and get
your thoughts and it's actually the
dedication of Jud Lake's book so at the
very beginning of the book here's what
he says in his dedication of the
book quote to Ellen White who remained
true to her prophetic calling in spite
of the scorn of her critics and left a
legacy of writings faithful to the Lord
Jesus Christ in his word the Bible close
quote so obviously Ellen White
apologists like Jud Lake have a very
different picture that they paint
regarding her and her Legacy what would
you say to any Adventists out there that
have only ever heard the sort of
whitewashing of Ellen White where she's
often painted as you know the humble
dedicated servant of God who overcame
all sorts of fiery arrows from Angry
critics and de demonized people like DM
canra
um despite her writings just being so
Jesus focused in all the other claims
that they love to make to paint her as
some sort of Saint what would you say to
uh that Adventist that's only ever heard
that you know
posturing you know all I can do is
encourage him to uh read my
psychobiography look at the sources look
at the source
documentation do the same with the white
estate fraud and then notice the
lifelong patterns we're not talking
about David committing adultery here the
lifelong patterns of dishonesty fraud
pathology cover up control manipulation
exploitation false testimonies
condemning many people that were proven
to be false there was no question that
they were false she simply made these
testimonies up uh false claims for
herself false claims of speaking for God
on all kinds of subjects that clearly
God did not speak on racism God hating
various children and ultimately
blasphemy you know when Ellen claims to
be the one who convicts of sin and
reproves sin that is the holy spirit's
job in the New
Testament Ellen is a liar and a fraud
and a blasphemer and she claims to be
the spirit of Prophecy which is the
testimony of Jesus and if you insult her
you insult the Holy Spirit you know this
is stuff uh that is just too ridiculous
in terms of lifelong patterns for a
person who claims to be the humble
servant of God um people can study and
read for themselves but uh to me the
evidence is so overwhelming that it's
just pitiful that these apologists keep
uh clinging to their
lies yeah Steve thank you for being here
I know it was a long uh a long evening I
appreciate your time um maybe we can
have you back sometime in the future to
maybe camp out on one thing in in
particular but I I definitely recommend
his book obviously folks please please
please consider picking this book up
it's on Amazon uh pretty pretty pretty
easy read and if they haven't read the
psychobiography this one should be read
first definitely um be yep because the
this one I can see how it Segways very
nicely off of a lot of the material
that's already covered in in that book
so Steve any final words that you'd like
to tell people where they can find any
sort of this stuff if they uh if it's
even an option to engage with you online
whatever it may be any final words that
you have yeah my thread on Facebook uh
is open to the whole public I've got
5,000 friends so if you want to that's
the limit so if you want to become a
friend put your name on the list and if
anyone drops out I'll try to include you
but um I don't make any money from my
books I've written 28 books uh it all
goes to charity so the accusations that
I write for money are false and um I
just want to uh have people pursue truth
and honestly uh weigh the evidence for
themselves I that's what I always say to
my church members don't take my word for
it uh test all things and hold fast to
what is good based on a Christ centered
spirit-led understanding of God's word
so um you know the perfect finished work
of Christ is the most important thing to
me in life and people who think I'm
obsessed with Ellen White are wrong but
I do think Jesus made it clear that we
are to uh Beware of false prophets and
scripture makes it clear that we are to
test all things including the
spirits and um so I don't apologize for
doing that and I I've heard from so many
people on my thread about what a great
difference it has made in their lives
and um so I I definitely believe it it's
a Ministry of God that he called me to
and I don't apologize at all for praying
about it when I was writing the
book oh you're one of the best hosts
I've I've never seen a host who did his
homework as much as you have and I've
been on 30 or 40 different interviews so
I'm very impressed with your work as an
interviewer and a host thank you uh well
thank you for all you do absolutely um
folks I I appreciate that a lot Steve
I'm going to let you go and I'll I'll do
our outro here you've been uh you've
been a treat and like I said maybe we'll
have you back sometime so thank you so
much for that there you go folks
um
adventus you just sometimes it's hard
to
um you know you feel like you're just
kind of beating a dead
horse like Steve
said we're not just here to grind an axe
there's better things that we could be
doing than uh just obsessing over over
something like this scripture's clear
Jesus gave instruction Paul gives
instruction Peter gives
instruction beware of false prophets
check this stuff against the scriptures
the Adventist Church loves to be or
claim to be the Commandment keeping
Church remember the ninth commandment
folks this is the SDA Church's favorite
commandment to
break it wasn't just Ellen White that
did this it's all sorts of people that
are associated with this
organization we only scratched the
surface tonight you can read Steve's
book and see how this is still impacting
real people real families
today
today this stuff
matters and we're a little bit more
fiery
here I've said that from the
beginning everyone's not called to be
that same way and I'm not saying
everyone else needs to be that same way
but on this platform we're going to name
names when they're making public
statements like this and they are
publicly lying about
people not cool with that nope and you
shouldn't be either if you really love
the
Commandments because it's wrong it's
wrong they've outright lied about Steve
dily as well as numerous other people as
we
saw but they've outright lied about him
by
name misrepresented him claimed that his
scholarship is
remedial who cares about the 326 you
know actual primary source documents
those are only you know appealing to the
The Not So informed
individual no no not cool not cool not
going to
fly we're going to keep doing streams
like this and try and contact other
people as well people that they've made
these sorts of claims about so people
can actually hear like the Proverbs say
Proverbs
18 you need to hear both sides of a
matter before you hear a person's
opinion you know SDA love to sling that
SDA apologists love to sling that verse
at this platform as if I stand opposed
to
that we're constantly talking about like
what Steve just said go check the
sources for yourself we don't hide any
of them they're always cited at the
bottom of the slides they're cited in
the description of videos go check it
out
yourself the purpose of tonight was for
you to be able to hear and see and weigh
the evidence yourself if you're an
Adventist it's time to get serious about
this this is not some some tertiary
issue this a life and death
issue this stuff matters it matters and
the SDA church does not understand the
gospel That's What It ultimately boils
down to you've got all this coverup
you've got all this collusion you've got
all this stuff going on behind the
scenes to to cover for Ellen White and
to keep the cash cow alive because
that's really what it's ultimately about
is power control
greed but at the root of all of that is
a false gospel it's a false Christ it's
a false god they claim to be the
Commandment keeping Church they have a
false god which means you're violating
all four all four of the first
Commandments the first four Commandments
because if you have a false god you
can't keep the other three Commandments
because they all four pertain to God and
if you have the false god you don't even
keep all four of them your favorite one
the fourth Commandment you're not even
keeping it because you guys don't
understand the
gospel the spirit of the law is
something much deeper than the the
simple letter of the law and adventism
is like a modern-day Israel in the sense
that old school Israel meaning oh yeah
we can keep the law we have the help of
the Holy Spirit now Jesus essentially
gave us a doover this sort of what what
Steve was talking about in in passing
earlier you know the model man Theory
Jesus being this great example
no friend no you don't get it you don't
get
it so it's time to get serious about
these
things please go and pick up his
book it's fantastic seriously it's
fantastic and pick up the
psychobiography as well it's also
fantastic and look at the resources
yourself he cites everything in there in
the bibliography as well as in the the
appendic is everything's in the back all
the not and you can access it all online
go start factchecking Steve and go and
check out and see if what he's claiming
is anything like these SDA Scholars are
claiming about
him he's not
unique he's just the most recent at
least that I'm aware
of person that has the Target on them
because like a can rer or whoever had
some sort of level of Academia or
notoriety if you will whatever it may be
within the organization and now that
they're actually spilling that
information out there they have to do
these sort of hit pieces no not gonna
happen not gonna
happen if you've been here the whole
stream God bless you thank you for being
here hopefully it was beneficial to you
hopefully it was educational like I said
maybe we'll get Steve back sometime we
will be back uh in next week TBD
possibly should be back next week we're
gonna be getting back into our response
to
John lomacang on uh apostate
protestantism and they claim that the
SDA Church are the true Protestants that
are really holding the line if you will
um yet no and then the week after that
we will be getting into a full stream
dedicated to Jud Lake some other claims
from his book but more uh uh
specifically a video presentation that
he gave that's essentially an overview
uh of his book so we will engage with
some of that as well and then some
Christmas content as well so buckle up
for that that should be uh pretty fun so
all that to say God bless you guys thank
you for being here and as always until
next time God
[Music]
bless